Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god, I'm like... I'm like so... I'm so emotional right now because 30 minutes before... 30 minutes before the stream was about to start, I decided to watch a video that was in my recommended for like a week now, and then I was like, oh, this video got to a million views within a week.
Oh, that's interesting.
Maybe I'll finally watch it.
I have 30 minutes to spare.
And I watched it, and I was tearing up.
I was like, no!
I have to stream in two minutes!
What is that?
I thought it would be a funny, interesting, ha-ha video!
Not like an emotional video!
It's not fair!
So, because, um, you know, it was a really good video, and I got really emotional about it, I am here to send it to you guys, so you guys can be really emotional about it too.
Because if I have to be, like, if this happens, if this has to affect me, I want it to affect everybody.
Um, basically, it's about this guy that decided, um, what he does is that his channel is that he goes through, like, he plays dead games, and just, like, just to see, like, what it's like.
So, there's a game called There.com, and I've never heard about it before, because it's, like, before my time.
Um, but it's basically, like, one of the first... it's basically before Second Life.
So, you guys know what Second Life is?
Um, it's, it's basically that, but it was before Second Life.
So, um, it was basically, like, a social media, uh, multiplayer game, where you just walk around and, like, talk to people, hang out with people, build a home there, and all of that.
Yeah, and, uh, and then there's, like, in-game voice chat as well, where you can talk to people, and, like, you know, type to people, and everything.
And apparently, it was really popular back in the day, and it's still running to the... but it's still running.
Like, you can still join it.
The only issue is that it has a membership fee, and that's why there's not a lot of people playing it now, because, like, Second Life is free.
But There.com has, like, a $10 subscription fee each month, but it's still alive in a way that there's still...
Apparently, there's, like, at least, like, 50 people that's still playing this game, because they've been in the game for, like, 10 plus years.
Because the game was around since 2003.
And, um, and there's some people there that's been in there since 2003, or, like, you know, and, you know, they made a lot of friends there.
They, like, you know, they made a lot of friends.
They made, like, uh, they, like, uh, bonded with a lot of people.
There's a lot of memories associated with it.
So, they're still playing.
They're still paying that $10 a month every, every month.
Uh, which is crazy to think about, like, the amount of money they've, like, invested in it.
And then there's, like, and then when you have houses in this game, uh, you have to pay, also pay an additional subscription fee as well.
So, the fact that these people are paying so much every month for around 18 plus years is actually insane.
But, like, the amount of memories that they share together and, like, the bonds they have is, like, they're, like, such a tight-knit group.
Like, they host events and everything every week.
And every week there's, like, events and stuff for the remaining players that are still there.
And I was watching it.
I was like, oh, my God.
And they're all close, close to each other.
It's like a little family.
Oh, my God.
And I, honestly, I highly recommend watching this video.
It's such, it's a really good video.
Um, it's such a good video.
And I was reading the comments, too.
And they're, like, oh, my God.
Like, oh, the memories.
Like, oh, it's so cool that you, like, you know, put a spotlight on this and everything.
And, oh, it's really sweet.
Um, yeah, it's, like, 20.
Yeah, they've been, like, some people have been playing this for 22 years.
They're, like, yeah, I, like, watched your kids grow up from this game.
And, like, um, and, like, this is, like, uh, like, I've, like, visited.
I've met a lot of these players in real life.
And this is, like, our way of, like, still talk, like, hang out with each other.
Even though we're, like, we live, like, from different places in the world.
And stuff like that.
I, I, just watch the video, honestly.
What I'm seeing is, does not, like, live up to, like, the actual video itself.
It was so emotional.
And I'm, like, coming into this game.
And I was, like, I was supposed to play Hihi HaHa Super Mario Bat.
And now, like, I feel, I have so much feelings in me right now.
I, I have, I have so much feelings.
Watch the video after the stream.
Anyway.
Uh, also, like, I need you guys to know, yesterday, I was so tired.
I was not, okay, I don't know why, but yesterday was, I had to, you know how I had to read a lot yesterday from all the games I was playing?
Um, from, like, Promise Mascot Agency.
And also, I guess, like, well, I didn't have to read for Friday Night Funk and Team Fortress 2.
But, I didn't read a lot yesterday.
And my brain was so fucking tired.
I actually, like, I went straight to bed right after.
I was not okay.
I was just, like, sleep time.
I was just, uh, reading made my brain eepy.
And I just went straight to sleep.
And I woke up at, like, fucking 7 in the morning.
And you know what I did at 7 in the morning?
I played Marvel.
Because I was just like...
Because I wanted to check out the new season.
And I'll just, and see, like, what it's like.
And I'll say, I'll, um, I'll say right now.
Um, I am definitely not gonna play this new season a lot.
Because it is dive meta for the newest season.
Because they basically, uh, buffed all the dive characters.
And then nerfed the anti-dive characters.
So, like, so, um, like, there's barely any support players anymore.
There's no!
There's no, there's no support players.
Because I was playing, I was, I was stacking, right?
And literally, I was literally the only person that was willing to play support.
Um, in the, because I was the only support main.
While I was, like, queuing up.
And, like, it almost, like, I think I had one game where there were two support players.
Including me.
And then every other game was just me being the singular support main.
And everybody else was just feeling to play support.
Um, and...
So, like, the reason why I'm saying that, like, playing support right now really fucking sucks, by the way.
Because, um, because when you get Dovan by Venom, Spider-Man, Captain America, Psylocke, uh, Black Panther, uh, Iron Fist, uh, The list goes on.
Uh, there is nothing you can do but die.
Like, it does not matter how well I fucking play.
I even had, uh, the other, I would look at the other support, we will heal each other.
I will use the, if I have an Iron Fist, I will use the Iron Fist C ability to, to, like, get HP.
I still die.
Me and the other support will have 10 plus deaths together.
And then, like, the rest of the team will be, like, 5 or 6.
And then me and my other support will be 10 plus deaths.
And it doesn't matter what character we play.
We will just die.
And the worst part is that, the, the worst part is that, then you're like, oh, Doki, just go Loki.
You know what the dive characters do?
They bad Loki.
You know what they do, the enemy team?
So there's nothing we can do.
And, and, and, and, so, um, so, also, the fact that, um, um, they all, the other thing they did was that, um, SR gains is now performance-based, but they forgot to create an algorithm for supports.
For, for SR gains.
So if you're a DPS or a tank, you get plus 30.
If you're a support, you get, like, plus 20.
If you're, if you do really, really well on support, you get plus 20.
And then you lose, like, you can lose 25 to 29 points.
Because, especially, like, you know how people are, like, oh, yeah, people are, like, oh, Rocket's actually really, really good now.
No one wants to play Rocket, because, because, um, like, people who actually want to climb don't really want to play Rocket.
Because Rocket has the most dogshit SR gains.
Because you don't do damage on Rocket.
But the SR gains, they calculate, for everyone, is healing and damage.
So, like, you know, you have to actually do damage to be able to, like, have higher performance-based SR.
So, like, so, like, you don't win.
And, like, that's just, I was, I had a game where I literally did the most healing on my, on both tees.
And we lost.
And I got minus 29.
I was like, what the fuck?
I got minus 29?
I was like, and then I got the most healing out of both tees.
I was like, oh my god.
But, yeah, um, Rivals is not really fun right now for support players, because there's just, there's no peel.
There's no character you can play that can, you know, as a support.
You'd literally have to, like, have half your team come backwards and peel for you to survive.
Like, even if you and the other support work together to, like, heal each other, we still die.
Like, we, we can't out-heal all the damage, because there's, like, at least three people trying to fucking kill me.
So, so, support players right now are, like, a dying breed at the moment.
And I'm not gonna lie, I'm not having fun playing Rivals.
I was playing, I played a couple of games, and I was so mentally exhausted playing Marvel Rivals.
Like, I actually was, like, even though, like, I wasn't in, like, VC or anything, I was just playing a game and just, like, just trying to see what the season's like now that the meta has settled.
And then I was literally, like, I was so mad.
I went straight to back to bed.
I was so fucking tired.
I was like, sleep time!
Exhausted!
I was like, alright, I'm E.P.
now.
Sleep time!
So, yeah, it's just not fun right now.
But, yeah, that's, like, more like a life update at the moment.
Alright!
So, today, today we are gonna be playing Super Mario Man!
Um, it is a, it is a ROM, it's a ROM hack, right?
Is that what it's called?
I've never, like, played these types of games before.
Um, but it's basically a fan-made ROM hack of, uh, of, you know, Super Mario, if it's Pokemon.
That's basically it.
Um, and it was made by Alpharad.
So, like, it was in development for, I believe, three years now.
And, uh, apparently it's, like, very well-made.
It's an incredibly well-made ROM hack.
And it is funded by one of the, you know, biggest YouTubers on the platform.
And, um, it looked really interesting.
I saw, like, Kony playing a little bit of it.
And it seemed incredibly interesting.
There seems to be a lot of love put into the game itself.
Uh, the last time I played Pokemon, like, I kept saying, I said this before, but the last time I played, like, the traditional Pokemon games, the formulaic ones, um, was when Pokemon X and Y was first released.
And for those who are, like, oh, man, that's not long ago.
Let me pull up the year X and Y was first released.
Pokemon X and Y was released in 2013, guys.
You're, like, oh, that's not long ago.
It was released in 2013.
And that was at...
And that was 12 years ago.
So, that was the very last time I played a traditional formulaic Pokemon game.
I never even finished Pokemon X and Y either.
Like, I stopped at the city where it was, like, based off of Paris.
I stopped at there where they had the Elfo Tower and everything.
Because, like I said, I was never really...
I never really liked...
Uh, like, I...
I got...
It got boring.
It got really boring and the games got incredibly easy.
So, like, I never really enjoyed the newer...
Like, the newer games because it felt like there was never anything sort of different.
I do still enjoy Pokemon designs and, like, other types of Pokemon media.
Like, the, um, the Legends games.
But I don't really enjoy the formulaic ones.
The, like, the traditional formula Pokemon anymore.
Just because I think it's been...
It's just really boring at that point for me.
For me, I just find it boring because I've been playing it for a long time.
And, um...
And it just doesn't interest me as much as it did in the past.
I don't know if it's just me growing up or I just, like...
Or I'm just, like, too used to the formula that...
That, uh...
That I wasn't, like, really much into.
Like, I just wanted something new to play.
Um...
Uh, so, yeah.
Uh, so, I heard a lot of good things about Super Mario 1.
And I'm really excited to try it out.
Uh, Tyrena, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jokey, now you're in the reading mood.
Wanna miss out on the flavor of the month...
Uh, coffin of, um, Andrew Ashley one.
What?
What the fuck is that?
Is that the...
Is that the incest game?
Is that...
Is that the game with the incest?
Yeah.
That was not flavor of the month.
That...
Wasn't that last year?
How did it become flavor of the month again?
I thought that was last year.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is why I should play more mutants.
Just say you love...
I'd rather...
You can't change my prejudice.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
In fact, I should hate them more because of Dive Meta.
You know who was involved in the...
In the Dive?
Psylocke.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Lolly, thank you for the Super Chat.
Izzy, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, the Eternals...
Oh, wait.
Money for Age of Ultron.
Lord Kurosis, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Toki.
Today is Zekra's birthday.
I was hoping you could wish him a happy birthday.
Of course I can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Zekra.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Alright.
Let's...
I wonder if I can...
Does the controller work on this?
I don't know.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, does the Xbox controller work?
For Mario Kart?
Okay, let me look at controls.
Uh, yeah?
Oh, maybe do I have to re-plug it?
Or do I have to boot it up with the controller plugged?
Oh no, I got it.
I figured it out.
Okay.
I don't... Hello?
Oh, it's not plugged in.
Oh, I have to set it up.
Okay, guys.
Guys, I'm figuring it out.
Alright.
Uh...
Where the fuck is the controller?
Okay, I thought I had everything set up, but apparently...
Guys, I'm new to this, guys.
I'm very new to this.
Okay, controller.
Okay, so...
How do I set this?
Okay.
That's A, B.
Alright, there you go.
Okay, I did it.
Okay, I set it up.
Alright, I figured it out.
Oh, I have to restart the emulator.
Okay, uh...
Let me reset this.
Alright, Super Mario Man.
Alright, I did it.
I figured it out.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah!
Alright, let me know if sounds okay, too.
Alright.
New game.
Difficulty...
Wait, what...
What can...
This feature is not support...
Then why...
Why am I looking at it?
Why show it to me?
If it's...
If...
If I can't...
Level cap off...
Oh, over leveling.
Oh my god, they can be like above level 100?
Okay, that's cool.
Any trainers are their default?
Plus capped at your highest level?
Okay, default, party limit.
Oh, I can like...
Have like more stuff.
Okay, trainer EVs.
I...
I never know what to do with EVs.
I don't understand EVs.
Um...
Wait.
Nuzlocke.
No Luzlocke, guys.
We are...
I would like to have...
Um...
I would like to have my...
Uh...
My Pokemon alive.
Thank you very much.
Uh...
If that is possible.
I'd like them...
I'd like them to be alive, guys.
Oh, it's the Luigi Professor.
The...
The Haunted Mansion.
Ah!
Finally!
A connection!
Nice to meet you.
I'm Professor Elven Dad.
But you can just call me E-Gag.
If you're out of shortening...
Of a shortening mind.
Now then, young fella.
Let me tell you about the world of the Mushroom...
Kingdom.
I was like, Mushroom?
Here's a Denison of the Mushroom Kingdom.
As a creature of the Mushroom Kingdom...
You'll be seeing many of these...
Throughout your adventure.
While they're usually the hostile sort...
You'll be getting very familiar with...
Yeah, it's Abu!
Why is that?
Oh ho ho!
You'll be finding out shortly.
Don't worry about that.
What?
Now then, allow me to introduce some fun young lads.
Oh my god!
These two are called Mario and Luigi.
They are the unlikely plumber heroes of the Mushroom Kingdom.
You'll be experiencing this journey through the eyes of Mario.
But what's your...
No!
I don't wanna be Mario!
I wanna be Luigi!
It's the year of Luigi!
Yes, you!
The one reading this!
Aww!
I'm sad.
Why do I have to be Mario?
You know like...
Nintendo almost went bankrupt because...
The year of Luigi did not make any money!
The year...
Oh my god!
I almost went...
Doki...
Um...
But the year of Luigi did not make them any money.
So like...
Uh...
So...
That's crazy.
So they stopped doing stuff like that.
Yeah.
Uh...
Unrelated but true!
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright.
So they don't do much for Luigi anymore because of it.
So it's Doki?
Wait, no.
Wait.
Okay.
Do I have to...
Oh, I have to do this.
I wanna say Doki Bird.
I wanna just be Doki.
I was like, no.
Ha ha ha ha!
No, I'm not Doki.
Uh...
Doki...
Wait, does it fit?
Oh, it didn't even fit!
Nevermind.
Doki-o.
Ha ha ha!
Okay, yeah.
Doki-o!
Louie!
I'm Doki-o.
Yeah, it's Doki-o.
It's-a me, Doki-o.
So you're Doki-o, eh?
We...
Well met then, Doki-o.
Alrighty, are you ready?
It's time to venture out into the Mushroom Kingdom.
Make sure to come see me in Toad Town.
I'm sad.
Why can't I be Luigi?
Luigi!
I just wanna be Luigi!
Oh, I can like...
Okay, I need to rebu- Guys, I need to rebuy all this.
Oh wait, there's a mushroom!
Wait, do I have a mushroom?
Oh my god!
Oh, I love the music!
I love the music already.
I love it so much.
Alright, I need to fix the...
Let me fix the controllers real quick.
Cause...
Uh...
I do not like the...
I set it up incorrectly.
It should be...
I set it up incorrectly there.
Bum...
Ba-da-da dum...
오...
I love the music!
Okay, i'll turn it...
I know that you said turn it down.
No!
A little bit, I'm sad.
Alright.
No!
Remember the sad times as much as the good times.
Tell everyone you love them.
Bad news.
Luigi!
Good morning, Mario!
Did you sleep well?
Still a little groggy?
Why don't you grab a mushroom from the fridge to get the day started?
That's my Luigi accent.
Mario!
Um, excuse me, it's Red Luigi.
Alright, I gotta get a mushroom.
Yeah, I got a mushroom!
Luigi!
Mail call!
Huh?
I'll get it, Mario!
Free mushroom, yeah!
Alright, turn the music down.
Let me know if it's better.
But, um...
It's a letter from Princess Peach.
How about I read it to you, okay?
Thank you, brother.
Dear Mario and Luigi.
I am hosting a worldwide party with help from Professor E.
Gag and friends from other kingdoms.
It should be a fun time with a prize again.
Oh my god, I'm gonna get my cake!
It will be over shortly to explain more.
Have fun!
I'm a simple Italian.
I'll come over as long as there's cake.
Signed, the princess!
This sounds super exciting, bro!
Let's meet the professor!
Tokyo has simple pleasures.
Tokyo just wants cake.
Luigi has become your partner.
Alright, Luigi.
Let's go meet my girlfriend.
Yahoo!
Alright.
I hope she makes lots of spaghetti.
Alright, that's my house.
Oh, that's my house!
Oh my god!
Those are the blocks!
Alright, boy.
Let's get going.
Once we get through here, we'll be in Toad Town.
It should take no time at all.
Wait!
Who's that?
Professor E!
Gagged!
We were just on our way to Toad Town to see you.
What's up with the letter the princess sent us?
Patience, my friend.
I'm a bit out of breath from running here and I'm also old.
What is it, bro?
Whew!
Okay.
I was going to wait for you two to arrive in Toad Town before I explained.
But then I remembered this path was here.
I can't have you stomping on Koopas and Goombas and the such who are participating in the game.
That's Mama Luigi to you, Tokyo.
I was thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
Now then, today, by request of the princess, I will be introducing you two to the Cap Challenge.
The Cap Challenge?
It's a game that has you build a party of allies or captures to battle each other.
Like baseball.
Yes, Luigi.
Just like...
Okay.
I don't think that's like baseball.
Like...
I just think he's like, yes.
Yes.
Definitely.
Like baseball.
Let's go ahead and get you and your brother started.
Luigi.
I don't think it's like baseball, Luigi.
Behind me is a piranha plant, a bob-bomb, and a blue bear.
Species such as these are an integral part of the event the princess is putting on.
I can only give a brief rundown here, but the princess will be explaining more at her castle.
Why should we play, professor?
If not, because it will be lots of fun.
But because the winners will be granted a wish.
Did you hear that, Mario?
A wish.
But what do the piranha plants and others have to do with this, professor?
I'm glad you asked, Luigi.
Contensors will be splitting themselves into two categories.
Those who command and those who move.
You'll be competing in battles of strategy, utilizing your capture's attacks called moves.
Here, the best way to learn is to just jump right into it.
Go ahead.
Pick whichever one you like.
You will go ahead and choose first, bro.
I don't mind.
Oh, you're trying to fuck me up, Luigi.
You're gonna choose my exact counter, aren't you, bro?
You want that- You want my princess.
I can tell, Luigi.
You have Daisy and her elephant.
That guy that's so fucking obsessed with Daisy and her elephant form.
You want the fire- Oh, wait, but ba-bomb is fire though, guys.
Okay, there is a blooper.
All right, do we get blooper or ba-bomb?
We don't do grass types in this household.
We are anti-grass here.
We are not touching any grass.
Ba-bomb or blooper, guys?
My bet's on.
Ah, they're both hard to pick.
All right.
I really, personally, I want- I want ba-bomb.
My first instinct was ba-bomb cause fire.
And fire good.
Look at him.
He's so angry.
And he looks just like dad.
Yes.
Mario the seed ba-bomb.
Would you like- Yes.
I'll name you dad.
All right.
Uh...
D...
Eh...
Oh, shit.
Dot, dot, dot.
D...
Uh...
Eh...
D...
Dad.
All right.
Nice.
Bring it down a little bit more.
All right.
No problem.
Let me know if it's better.
I think that's down.
Wait.
Actually, let me double check.
All right.
Yeah.
All right, Luigi.
Your turn.
I'll choose this.
Oh.
He's stupid.
Luigi.
That's why there's no more hero of Luigi.
That's why mom likes me more.
hier...
It's grass.
Oh, I like how we all have Cappy.
Send out Bitey.
Go, Dad!
Oh my god, he's about to explode.
Okay, let's work together.
Alright, but...
I'll take you down with me.
What?!
No way!
Are you serious?!
How do I fuck that up?!
He lives!
Why did he beat me?!
I took him down with me!
Luigi won by doing nothing at all!
I can't believe it!
He won by doing nothing at all!
That's so fucked up.
I can't believe I lost the happy year of Luigi.
You did amazing, Bitey!
And what a wonderful battle!
Okay, now I know.
No!
Now then, in order for someone to be a party party...
A pasta la pizza, Dokio!
Mask!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
They need to wear a specially designed cap I created!
The members you chose already have them!
But you're gonna need some more in the future!
Here!
They're in this care package!
Oh, yeah!
I received the care package!
No!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
He picked the weaker Pokemon so it will sing more when he won anyway!
Look!
He won by doing nothing!
I was the one that fucked up!
Inside it, obtain the caps!
Yay!
Alright, I got the Pokeballs.
These caps will also shrink down your creatures so that you may travel alongside you more easily!
It's just his aura!
Inside the package is also my patent-pending Tattle Dex!
When Link Girl Researcher and Scientist have compiled every capture strength as well as a quippy excerpt about them!
Alright, nice!
I got a Tattle Dex!
Now then, I suggest you two start heading to the castle as soon as you can!
This is not fair!
My self-destruct should have took him down with me!
We're the same level!
Well, bro!
I'm gonna head off to Toad Town!
Maybe I'll see you along the way!
What happened to being partners?!
What the fuck, Luigi?!
I thought we were partners, bro!
Oh, nice!
Oh, that's me like hitting the...
It's like the little mini Pokeballs!
Bro!
Oh, it doesn't do anything!
What happened to being partners?!
You're too weak!
Smell you later!
Oh, what's this?
Ant Ruper!
Oh, dad!
Alright!
Okay, we're not self-destructing this time!
We're...
We're just gonna do...
Why do I have non-fire moves?!
Why do I have an electric move?!
Alright, let's get Ant Ruper!
Alright!
Defense rises, let's capture you!
Where's my capture?
Plumber cap!
Let's go!
How does this look like?
I like how it rotates too!
Yay!
I get an Ant Trooper!
That gained 12 XP!
Yay!
What is the data?
An oversized insect is a tireless worker often used to transport goods.
Its shoes act like suction cups, and it can walk alongside walls and ceilings.
Alright!
Do you have a nickname to capture?
Yeah!
Alright!
What do I nickname you?
I shall nickname you...
You know what?
Let's just do dragoons!
This entire...
My team will just be filled with dragoons!
And the stronger you...
If you're strong enough, I'll put you in my...
Put you in my team!
Alright!
Uh, DJ!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Congratulations!
You played yourself!
Alright, guys!
At first...
Who wants to be part?
Who wants to be Ant Trooper?
That...
You're gonna be put in the PC, by the way!
Alright!
Who wants to...
Me!
Alright!
Let me see who...
Not me!
Alex!
Because you don't wanna be in it, I'll put you in!
It's okay!
I'm putting you...
I'm never gonna use you in a fight anyway!
Alex!
Don't worry!
You're gonna live in the PC!
I am...
I ain't having no bug!
I'm gonna get...
Don't worry!
Watch this!
I ain't having no bug in my party!
That poor soul!
Reverse psychology worked!
It's alright, Alex!
You're going in the PC!
I specifically went back just to deposit you!
Oh, I can't!
Not yet!
Goddammit!
I can only deposit items for now!
Alright, don't worry!
At the next...
Pokemon Center, I'll put you in the PC!
I ain't having no bug type in my party!
I can't!
Oh, wait!
Nice!
I got another one!
What's this?
Oh my god!
It's a Koopa!
Wait, what?
Is this...
What type is the Koopa?
Oh!
Alright, let's see.
Let's use charge.
Tail whip?
Oh my god!
They have their own tails!
Alright, what does charge do?
Oh!
Oh, that's a stat thing!
Okay, I thought it was...
I don't...
I don't know a lot of mood types.
A critical hit!
Get out of here!
Is this a normal?
Oh, you're definitely going into my PC.
I ain't having no normal types in my...
I'm not having...
Ain't no...
Having no normies in my party.
I don't know.
I think I had like a stroke there.
So it's useless.
Exactly.
Alright.
Yay!
Koopa T was caught!
The Koopa Trooper!
Yay!
A turtle that is beyond loyal to the king.
The bottom of the shell is made of a low friction material that allows it to slide across the ground.
Alright.
What do we...
Alright, who wants to be the next Dragoon?
I feel like you could just be normal Dragoon.
No, we should name Dragoon for an actual Dragoon.
Like a dragon.
Alright.
Let's see.
Uh...
Oh my god.
Chad is moving so fast.
Chad is moving so fast, I don't know who to pick.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Uh, alright.
The...
Wait.
Where's the...
Oh shit.
Oops, I have to do this again.
Ha ha ha ha!
The...
Don't worry, you're also going into the...
You're going into the...
You're going into the PC.
You're a normal type.
You don't matter in my party.
Uh...
Where is it?
Oh my god.
I wish this was...
I wish I have a stylus right now.
And I could be like...
Wait.
Can I type it?
No.
Fuck!
This is the worst part.
Yeah.
Dragoon.
Alright.
Here we go.
Now we have to...
Hello, Louie.
Hey, bro.
You have your hammer on you?
If you do...
You can break...
Crack bricks like those.
Well then.
Now that I've done all my brotherly duty...
I'll be heading on to the toadown.
Oh, and don't forget to use your hammer?
Question mark box as well.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, I can just press it.
I don't have to...
Actually bring it up.
I got a chef cap.
Is that like a better cap?
Oh, hey, toad!
Oh.
Oh, I got a goomba!
Is this also a normal type?
Pay to win.
Gross.
Can I be a dragon type?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, but you can be a goomba.
Because you want it to be a dragon type?
I'm giving you goomba duty.
That's right.
Now you're gonna be a goomba.
No!
That's right.
You're on the bottom of the food chain.
What if I just only level up, dad?
I'll make him like the strongest Mario Mon of all the land.
An angry, yet powerless mushroom.
That's you!
Its reputation as a weakling is earned.
It is said to be a traitor, abandoning unworry trainers during battle.
Yes.
All right.
You're gonna be my bench warmers.
Oh my God.
What if I do that?
Oh, wait.
I like...
Okay.
I like that.
Dragosis.
Like everybody will have...
We'll start with R.
All right.
I like that.
I like that idea.
Drag...
Osis.
It's like...
It's like Digimon where it ends in Mon.
But it starts...
It's...
It starts on...
It starts on Dra. Dra...
Oh wait.
I spelt it wrong.
Whoops.
How do I...
Dra...
Osis.
Everyone just...
Or...
Krogoon.
Or maybe Goon.
Okay, guys.
Guys.
Do we do...
Do we...
Do we end on...
Oh, it can't end on Goon.
You're right.
I think they'll block me.
Dryosis.
I don't know.
Does it...
Or do we do Goon?
Guys.
We're experimenting.
One to one is rather small, don't you think?
But at least things are peaceful.
Hello.
Do we do Goon?
Alright.
Goon.
Okay.
We'll end on Goon.
Goon.
Alright.
We'll just kill you.
Koopa T.
I pity the boo.
Wait.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm playing the long game.
Not asking to be a Pokemon now.
So I can be a good one.
She'll actually use later.
I am very smart.
Manny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I will use Goon.
We're experimenting.
That's why the others are on their PC.
That's why the others will be on the PC.
Alright.
I'm just gonna level up.
Dad.
Who cares about my other Pokemon?
What?
So are you saying I get stomped by Goki?
Pretty sure some Diggoers are gonna say it should've been me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you- Yeah, but you'll get stomped once before you're dead.
Uhh.
Let's see.
Rae, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Alright.
Found one mushroom.
Oh, nice.
That is all I need.
Alright, oh wait, there's like a... Oh!
Oh, I can't do anything there yet.
Fuck.
Oh, I'm like stuck in this one area.
Don't worry, it's just level grinding.
My one trick.
Nothing can beat him!
There's no way I'll fight a water type!
Getting stopped by Dookie is once enough.
I'll take it.
Thank you for the super chat, Nexy.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I'm just shiny hunting, okay?
Nice, critical hit.
Look, I'm leveling him up now, so I don't have to level him up later.
I'm just playing this long game here.
Alright.
I'm out here collecting flowers to sell, back at Tone Town's Market.
Cool.
That's it?
Alright.
How about you?
This entrance is so relaxing.
Thanks to you, of course, Mario.
Nobody would ever cause trouble, given your home is right past one to one.
Oh, it's the world!
I was like, what the fuck, one one?
And I forgot that's what Mario worlds are called.
One one.
Lord, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, they gunify me, Dookie.
Since grosses hate birds, can I be a flying type?
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, Tone Town.
Okay, nice.
Welcome to Tone Town, Mario!
Looking for the professor?
He went on ahead to Princess Peach Castle already.
Just head east from here, and you should eventually reach the castle.
Alright, nice.
It can't be that difficult.
Wait, who are you?
How do I talk to you?
Shaman has wares for the right people.
Hmm.
You're not someone who can handle my wares.
Come back when you have one- I need to get a power star!
I need to go fucking play Mario Party!
Are you listening to me, dear?
We still have a long ways to go today!
Oh!
Mario!
Talk some sense into this girl, will you?
She has no respect for her elders!
I can't open up a shop until she helps me gather ingredients!
Mario!
Please help me!
I want to try the captain challenge as well!
But my grandfather won't let me!
Fuck yeah!
I don't know how people can do this voice all the time.
Alright.
Oh, wait!
Wait, those are regular berries!
Wait, those are regular Pokemon berries!
What?
I thought everything was Mario themed!
Alright, let's see.
Is there anything in here?
Why is there regular Pokemon berries in my Mario-mon game?
Oh, there's the...
There's the Pokemon Center!
Hello!
You're still- Yep.
Please...
Please recover...
Please recover my one Pokemon.
Alright.
Into the PC, you go!
Oh, wait, no.
That's not what I wanted.
Wait, can I do this?
Oh.
I didn't do the deposit.
Alright.
Move capture.
Into the PC, you go!
Goodbye!
This is your home now!
You live on my computer!
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
I have named access to rare cannons regardless.
To do so, you need consent to enabling the content creator mode.
With this option enabled, you'll be able to receive as many rare cannons and coins as you like.
However, you'll be unable to turn this- Oh my god!
It will be on my permanent record!
Would you like to- The content creator mode is like- Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
It should have been called journalist mode.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
Alright.
Oh, I should- Wait, I can rename the box.
You're right.
You are a content creator.
Do I just give- Do I just go easy mode, right?
You're right.
I should rename the box.
Uh, wallpaper.
What are the different- Snow, cave...
Oh, you guys should be in the cave.
There we go.
Name.
I'll rename the box.
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
What do you name it?
Um...
Exiled.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Exciled.
There we go.
Prison!
There you go.
Please go.
They're exiled to the Goon Cave.
We all know what cave it is.
We don't have to taxi it.
No worries.
Alright.
See ya.
Oh, hey.
There are 150 different captures to record in your Taldex, but I've also heard rumors of a crazy powerful capture that's number one.
151.
Hey Mario!
Keep yourself safe!
It's dangerous out there.
Wait, you just said keep yourself safe.
I'm sorry, but the second floor is currently on the... Oh, wait a minute.
Whoa, Toad!
It's like the Toad in the Epic Universe.
Where, um, where...
If you, if you, like, scan your Mario watch, it shows the Toad flipping you off.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm friendly.
Not all Koopas and Goombas are playing the game.
So don't hesitate to talk to us.
Not all Koopas, guys.
Hey, Mario!
I hear you're taking part in the cap challenge.
If you ever come across a Yoshi, would you mind showing me?
And if you do, I'll even give you a reward.
Alright.
Nice.
The quest Yoshi lover is now active.
Whoa.
How much of a lover are you?
I wonder how many worlds out there.
Eight worlds?
Wow.
Eight worlds.
Hashtag not all Koopas.
Where does this go?
What is this?
Welcome to the Warpstone.
Unfortunately, we're going on the growing maintenance.
Please exit the town and use the east exit.
Do I go to World 3 or World 4 first?
I can't decide.
The Warpstone was a genius idea planned by Professor E.
Gag.
With the help from Princess Peach.
It makes it much easier for everyone to get to all worlds.
Alright.
One toad's going to be like fucking...
What was it?
Keegan?
Uh, Michael.
Oh my god.
What was it?
Keegan Peel?
One is going to be Peel.
So I don't have to do this voice all the time.
Alright.
Sorry.
The battle school is closed at the moment.
Come back when things are ready.
Bro.
Everything is closed in Toad Town.
Is anything open?
Hey there, Mario.
Heading out to 1 too?
There's something you might want to know if you're heading out there.
Do you know about Quest?
You should always be keeping an eye for troubled citizens of the Mushroom Kingdom.
Make sure to help anyone out if you see them.
Can I go out?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
No non-toads allowed in my Toad Town.
I've been hearing rumors that Bowser Jr. is now king of the Mountain Kingdom.
That can't be true.
I wonder how Bowser is here about that.
I don't know how Mint can sing in this voice.
Wait, is this a gym?
No.
That's just a trap there.
The storehouse is such a mess.
Am I having?
I'm in here.
He's going to clean us up this mess.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I did it.
Nice.
Don't worry.
Legally stealing your stuff.
I'm just helping you.
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah.
Wait, I got a TM.
I never use...
I never use the TMs at all.
I don't care as much.
I just use the moves they give me.
Alright.
What's up here?
Hello, Toad.
Do you have anything in your trash I can steal?
My best friend left for a trip to the Cloud Kingdom.
I haven't heard it for me since.
I hope she's doing alright.
Alright.
That was...
A waste of my time.
Different captures have different types.
I want to find all the bug type ones.
Oh my god.
Are you...
Don't be a loser.
Bug types are the worst.
We're in a very intense chess match.
So if you can...
Please excuse us.
Where's the chess?
It seems to be eating a piece of...
Okay, look.
He's talking in his mind.
So, like, in his mind, he does not sound like Toad.
Back in my day, we didn't have capture centers.
We have good old-fashioned one-ups.
And if you didn't have extra one on you, then it's game over.
I'm back to the start.
Huh?
I can't hear you.
Oh, he's old.
Oh my god, he's old!
Look at him!
Oh my god!
He's so old!
Oh my god, he's...
Okay, I...
Alright, guys, let me see.
Oh my god, he's so old.
I think he's at least 30.
Okay, I...
JK, JK, I didn't mean that, guys.
I didn't...
I didn't mean that.
Bro is...
I didn't mean that, guys.
I'm joking.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's a fan club for me!
Alright, if their fucking conversation is not relevant, I'm not gonna read it.
Okay.
I love Super Mario Bros.
3!
Okay, that was incredibly relevant.
I...
Are they all just being like, I love Super Mario Bros.
3?
Is that it?
Oh my god, that's really it.
That's the Super Mario Bros.
3.
It's...
It's all just a marathon Super Mario Bros.
3 speedrun thing.
Oh my god.
When they said fan club of Super Mario Bros.
3, it was actually a fan club.
Excuse me, Mario, right?
Am I doing you a favor?
My grandson went out to 1, 2 a few hours back.
And hasn't come back.
I'm just fraught with...
Wait, won't you please go search for him?
Kuma, think about the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I love Super Mario Bros.
3!
Dr. Yuriko, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, he's definitely dead.
The brother of mine always going out exploring.
Niggly is just reckless, not stupid.
He should be alright.
They keep taking her Marvel Rivals Rage out on the track.
Oh, you want me to out?
No, no, no.
I'll show you what actual rage is like.
Alright, let me...
Alright.
Alright, I will draw...
No, actually...
No, I'll get the Goomba out.
Give me a sec.
You can stay in the box.
Alright.
You want to know what real rage is like?
Let me...
Alright, let's see.
Oh, you're level 2.
That's perfect.
Alright, let's go out in the grass.
Don't worry.
We'll progress soon, guys.
We'll progress soon.
Oh, man.
Oh, shit.
Another Goomba.
Oh, man.
What's going to happen to Dryosis?
Let's try and run.
Oh, you can't escape.
Oh, that's so unfortunate.
Oh, no.
Oh, you got the first hit.
Don't worry.
I'll let sure you get a tackle in.
Let's...
Oh, my God.
That's your damage?
That's your...
Alright.
Oh, look at you go.
Wow.
Look at you go.
Fight back, buddy.
The slow and painful death.
He's so weak.
Do anything.
He is trying his best.
Which is the sad part.
Alright.
Next up.
It's your turn.
Get up.
Grandpa.
It's your turn.
Oh, man.
Don't worry.
His defense fell.
You're going to be so...
You're going to have such a strong attack when it's your turn.
Oh, man.
Don't worry.
I'll make you attack soon.
Don't worry, you're gonna have your turn.
Oh, she's killing that.
Nevermind, keep me out of your game, you sadist.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alright dad, go sweep this up for me.
Go do your thing.
Alright, nice.
How is he faster?
He's level 3!
Aw man, thanks for weakening him for me.
Dryosis and D-Dragon.
I appreciate it.
Alright, nice, we did it.
See, alright.
Now, did you guys learn your lesson?
You must.
Did you learn your lesson, guys?
Alright.
Maybe support players deserve to be oppressed.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Oh my god, I don't even heal you.
You just go straight back into the box.
Alright, nice.
Not one bit.
Now the ant will know.
The ant will know not to fuck with me.
Man, I wish I was getting publicly humiliated like that by Toki.
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Aye!
The salty breeze never fails to tug at me heartstrings!
Fancy a story from an old- Oh my god, guys, I cannot.
Alright.
In his mind, in his storytelling head, it's like a normal voice.
Many moons ago, me ship, the seabird, was caught in the fiercest storm I've seen.
The waves were mountains and the wind screamed.
It's like when Donald Duck ate this pill that made him sound, like, really hot.
We fought tooth and nail to keep the vessels afloat as the sea toyed with us.
Just when it seemed like the sea was to take us, we fought it beaking a light through the rain.
It was a lighthouse, and it saved our hides that night.
We moved to it like mobs to the flame, until we saw the lighthouse keeper frantically waving us away.
He knew the dangers of his rocky shore, and he was trying to save us from being scurried.
Yeah, there was no way I was reading this in the toad voice.
We managed to steer clear of the jagged rocks and found shelter in a cove.
We spent the night there, waiting out the storm.
The next morning, when the skies cleared, we want to thank the lighthouse keeper who had disappeared with all the traces...
Oh my god, he was a g-g-ghost!
We couldn't even find a lighthouse that guided us the night before.
Ah, you've been a fine audience.
It warms my heart to know there are still folks like ye who appreciate the old stories.
Here, take this.
Yay!
I got a rare candy!
Dusty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm one of the playtesters for this, and I hope you enjoyed the game as much as I did.
It's so cool seeing you play this wrong, my friends.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, it's been fun so far.
It's been fun sending, um, um, sending people, sending my dragoons out to fight.
Come back, and once you've grown some hair on chests, and I'll tell another tale.
But I'm Italian!
I already have hair on my chest!
Ah, the ocean is so nice this time of year!
I wonder my head will let me float in the water!
Wait, I got rare candy!
You know what that means.
Uh...
Wait, what's the baseball cap?
Oh, it has a...
Oh, that's the great ball!
Okay, uh...
Alright, I'll give it to the one...
Wait, actually, what level...
I think I'm about to level up Dad, so let me double check real quick.
Where is it?
Oh yeah, he's about to level up.
I shouldn't give it to him.
I'll give it to him when he levels up.
See, he's strats, guys.
What's this?
Mario!
I wish I could be part of the cap challenge!
I'll stay here and watch the screen!
Why?
Because I was told to!
Good Toad's follow orders!
I'm a handyman!
That means I'm a...
Oh my god, I should not have read that.
That's a waste of a toad voice.
We see a lot of ships come in!
But nothing like the Odyssey you brought in earlier!
She should be repaired some months from now!
So check in then!
My brain is a hundred percent toad!
Alright, now I have to pick and choose who gets the toad voice.
This is too many.
I can't believe there are so many toads in Toad Town!
Okay, yeah.
Oh, I have to get eight power stars.
Okay, guys.
Sorry, this was not important enough to be read.
out loud.
And then...
Sorry, guys.
That was not important enough.
Too many toads, one might say.
Alright, guys.
I'm picking and choosing.
This is not relevant information, guys.
Oh!
I heard that buying ten plumbing caps at once gets you a free cap!
I'm gonna try and capture only those caps!
Every toad line...
Toki, you don't understand.
Each toad line is very integral to the part of Super Mario mod.
If you miss one line, it's over.
This run is dead.
Alright, off I go.
Oh, World 1-2.
Mario!
You made it to World 1-2, huh?
From here on out, there will be other toads.
Get you to try out this new game the princess came up with.
Make sure I give you all you got!
Yeah!
Okay, is he gonna fight me?
Fight me, toad!
Hey, Mario!
Ken!
Ken the toad!
Let's battle!
Oh!
They have names?
I thought they're all just toads!
Oh my god, it's Youngster Toad.
Oh my god, he brought a Goomba to a toad fight?
Alright, goodbye Goomba.
Destroy Ken, my boy Ken!
Get out of here Ken!
You brought a Goomba to a toad fight?
You should've fought- You should've just fucking fought yourself, toad.
Why can't I catch the toad?
Whoa!
So that's a cat battle!
Anywhere else he'd be a dead.
Oh, do I get new- new mons?
No, it's still a Koopa.
Be shy, welcome to tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Oh, and you're saying Koopas are not- Don't deserve rice either?
What about the poor Koopas?
They also live in a village too!
They are part- They're citizens in Koopa Village!
What a- They don't count.
Not- Not in Toad Town.
Okay, wait, let me uh- Let me use my rare candy now.
Alright, nice.
Only- Only Yoshi lives matter.
Wait.
No, I don't like- Yeah, stop trying to- Yeah, Screech is not a good move.
I don't like using the stat moves.
I'm not one- I'm- I'm those people.
I'm like the ones that just use all attacks.
I'd never use stat moves.
Not all Koopas.
Like- Alright!
If I- If- A Koopa is literally in the Pokemon Center right now trying to talk to me.
Hehehehe.
So like- Why can I catch him when I can't catch a toad?
They're like the same size.
Alright, let's go- Yeah, the only stat change that matters is... exactly.
It's reducing their HP to zero.
You get it.
Hey, Mario!
Have you seen any of the warp pipes yet?
All you gotta do is go up to them and jump on in!
Oh, cool.
I'll try it.
Yay!
Wait, where am I?
Mario, what are you... I lost it.
What are you doing here?
What?
My grandpa still gets lost out here?
That's ridiculous.
How did anyone get lost in such a small space?
Oh, I get it.
They're probably wondering where I wandered off to.
Again.
Here!
If I hear your body...
Oh my god, I could've been healed here!
Wasting my time.
Oh, nice.
Do I have to go back to the grandpa and be like, he's not lost?
Oh my god!
Oh, it's that song!
Oh my god, it's so cute!
They used the...
The under... The cave song!
Yeah, the underground scene.
Where am I?
I can't do anything here, though.
Oh, I can jump down from here.
Oh!
Alright, fight me.
I think you're prepared?
What's his name?
Youngster Shigeru would like to battle.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, it's an electric thing!
It's those, like, electricity things!
On the, like...
Oh my god, my...
Dad is so slow.
I mean, it makes sense because he's like...
Uh...
He, like, walks up.
Alright, Monty...
Oh, it's Monty Mole!
Wait, I want a Monty Mole in my party!
Wait, that's so cute!
Oh, it's super effective.
Alright.
Monty, my boy!
I wish I could, like, steal their Pokemon.
Like, uh...
The Pokemon Dark series.
The Shadow Luigi...
Luigi one.
Luigi...
Shadow Luigi...
Um...
Lugia...
Sorry!
Shadow Lugia...
Shadow Luigi...
Lots of toads!
Love going for walks out here!
Although things have been a bit more exciting thanks to the cab!
I don't know where I can find...
Maybe...
Whew!
Now I just gotta go through one of these castles in order to make it to Peach Castle!
I gotta enter a castle in order to get to another one?
Something's kind of odd, if you ask me!
I'm growing my team!
Check them out!
Yeah, a stinking leg...
Oh!
Shit!
No!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I spilled my iced tea!
Oh, no!
Oh!
SOS!
No!
Oh!
I did it again!
Okay, give me a sec, guys.
I gotta clean.
Oh, no.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh!
I had an open brisk iced tea.
Not again!
It's okay.
It's not okay.
But it's okay.
Oh, no.
Be a sec.
Let me clean this.
Oh, no.
I-I just put it...
I just capped it up.
Oh!
Not again!
I'll be right back!
Luigi failed me!
I played Luigi.
This is Luigi's fault.
The sound.
Oh my god.
No!
I got it on the floor!
The sound.
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, it's always Luigi's fault!
Okay, I gotta clean up the floor real quick.
Oh, it's so hard.
I just got my apartment clean.
Oh.
Oh, I was coming!
Sorry, I spilled risk eyes to you.
Oh, I'm like, I'm getting it up.
Right now.
Oh, I'm just sick.
I have... Okay, the worst part is that I had my, like, fighting game controller.
The Razor one on the floor.
It was... It may or may not have been on the floor and got stashed by the water.
Oh, no.
Guys, it's okay.
It means I might not be playing any time soon.
I blame Luigi.
This is Luigi's fault.
This is why your gear failed and made zero profit for Nintendo.
And the... That's fucking where I said it.
Okay, I'm drying this out real quick.
Oh, my floor is gonna be sticky now!
No!
Not the sticky floors!
That's the worst part.
When your floors become sticky.
Why couldn't it just be water?
My water bottle was next to the fucking brisk ice tea!
Sticky!
Oh!
I hate it when it's sticky!
I have cleaning products, but, like, I don't think I have time.
I'll clean this later.
I'll use cleaning products for it later.
Oh, fuck.
No, my drinks was next...
It was on my right-hand side, uncapped.
My brisk ice tea.
And I accidentally smacked it.
You know, the worst part is that I also spilled, like, orange juice on my keyboard yesterday.
Like, just...
I'm just extra clumsy.
I...
Like...
And, like, that's...
This never happens to me!
The last two days, I'm just spilling drinks left and right!
You know what?
This is why I should have kept drinking water.
Usually, I'm, like, water only.
But, like, the last couple of days, I was feeling a little quirky.
I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna drink something else that's not whining!
I'm gonna drink orange juice!
I'm gonna do it!
And then, of course, I spill orange juice.
I...
Alright.
Let's use ember.
It's a bug-type anyway.
Nice.
Goodbye, Ant Trooper.
Goodbye.
Only 7 XP?!
Oh my god, what the fuck is that?!
A Biddybud?
Okay, clearly, I, like, I'm out of the Mario lore.
There are some things that I don't know.
The fuck is a Biddybud?
What game does that come from?
How big do you want your team?!
It's just gonna be one Pokemon.
Unless...
Unless they're worthy!
I'm a one-mon type of gal.
Oh, I never played 3D World.
I don't think I have played it.
Yeah, Battles!
Sure are attempts, aren't they, Mario?
Um...
Hey, KB, thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
It was me, Doki.
I was the one who slightly moved your brisk ice tea over to make it seem like you were the one who split and make your floor sticky.
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Warkybird!
Hey, Dorkyo!
Send us- send us some of that super gold my way!
Hey, thank you in the super chat, worky bird.
Oh no, it's worky.
Alright.
Oh, it's a guy over there.
I was like, why won't it let me through?
Wait, did I come from here?
Yeah, this was my warp portal.
Okay, let me... I'm gonna have to talk to the grandpa and be like, I found your son.
Alright, go dad, go.
Okay, let me just kill everything here, so I don't have to grind later.
I just, uh, that's like my biggest peeve about, like, Pokemon games, is that, like, you have, like, the grinding part.
If you don't grind enough, you have to, like, go... you have to, like, go back and just start fighting mons.
But just naturally start fighting them now.
Then I don't have to worry.
Oh yeah, that's not it.
That's not where I want to go.
Alright!
Where is... where does grandpa live again?
No, that's not where he is.
They were doing, like, mine chest or whatever there.
I think here, right?
Oh yeah, the content... yeah.
But if I use content creator mode, I know my chat is gonna never let me live this... live through it.
For the sake...
For the sake of my mental, I have to not use content creator mode.
It would be 10 years later.
If I'm still streaming 10 years later, they'll be like, Remember the time you tried to use content creator mode in Super Mario mode?
I remember.
Where the fuck does he live?
Here?
No, that's like the battle thing.
Alright.
Where the fuck?
Where did he live?
I checked every house.
Oh my god, I don't remember.
There's so many toad houses.
They all look the same.
No, that's like...
That's where they were playing mind chess.
And this is like...
The 30 year old people.
This is where the 30 year olds live.
No, that's the Pokemon.
I love Super Mario Bros 3.
Oh, there you go.
I found your son.
What's that?
My son is alright?
Thank you, Mario!
Wait, that's it?
I don't even get money?
The fuck?
I don't even get money for this quest?
I found your fucking...
He's your only son, I assume.
I assume the other one's a daughter.
He's the only son you care.
And I get nothing out of it?
That's...
I'm leaving him die in that cave.
I'm getting my Monty Moe, too.
Yeah, he's so ungrateful.
Nice.
Oh, yay!
There are Monty here.
Oh my god, it's Buzzy B!
He must be really strong, right?
He hates his son.
No, he actually made...
He doesn't love...
No, I think a better thing is that he doesn't love him enough.
Alright, how much...
What is his type?
Oh my god, he's so cute.
Or she's so cute.
Oh!
Get in my ball!
Or get in my cat!
Oh, he's a dark type?
Okay, we need dark type.
Dark type is always good.
I'll level you up later when I get an EXP share.
Come on, get in here.
Oh my god.
Alright, let me tackle it.
I can't be that strong, right?
Oh, nice.
Just enough.
Get in my cat!
Yeah!
Got a dark type!
And I got EXP!
Let's go!
Nexy, you want to be Buzzy B?
Yeah, of course, Nexy!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you, Nexy Goon!
A secluded turtle that lives in caves and sewers.
It's hard.
Capropage gives it fire resistance.
Its sticky feet allows it to take refuge on ceilings.
Alright.
Nexy...
Goon...
Where the fuck is the G?
I don't know my alphabets.
Oh, there...
Goon...
Where's the N?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
The Goonification.
Wait, there has to be more down here, right?
Is there the Monty Mole?
I want the Monty Mole.
Oh, no.
It's just...
Don't forget to hold...
I thought that was a myth.
That was an urban legend.
Thank you for the super chat, V-Shark.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't worry.
There's 150 of them.
Oh, never mind.
I guess I'm not fighting that.
I wonder if there's more in this cave.
Oh, my God.
It's a Geodude.
Another PC Pokemon.
Okay, tackle.
Okay, it's not very...
I don't think fire...
Fire is not...
Um, excuse me.
Oh, my God.
It's legally distinct Geodude.
Put me on the bench, coach.
Okay, tip.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God.
I love my legally distinct Geodudes.
The PC hunger is for more.
All right.
Let me just slowly tackle.
Bro, what do you mean Rapism is a good move?
It did, like, two damage.
All right.
Get in there.
Get in my cap.
All right.
Yay!
Bro, there.
It's caught.
What is it?
A living boulder of eyes and arms.
It rolls around, trampling plants and bugs in its path.
In groups, it is known for its strong sense of camaraderie.
Meep would like to join the Goon Cave.
Another one to the Goon Cave.
Back, axe, exiled.
All right.
Let's see.
Tips.
Tips, Goon.
It's just like Digimon.
I wish, like, I could just type this out instead of having to fucking write this.
All right.
Is there any more?
Wait, is there the last sun?
Heal me.
Oh, okay.
After this fight, heal me.
All right.
Get out of here.
Out strong.
Oh, my God.
These will take forever.
Wait.
He has Metal Claw?
All right.
Nexty.
I'm gonna catch this and then release old Nexty.
I think he might be better.
All right.
It's okay.
This is you, but better.
Nexty too.
All right.
Wait.
He's got Metal Claw.
No!
He broke three!
The Cooler Nexty.
Okay.
I might be able to tackle him.
No!
The Cooler Buzzy!
It was just not meant to be.
Oh, my God.
I killed it!
Kaz, thank you for the super chat thing.
Put me in.
He's both just like me.
Rest in peace.
Nexty 2.0.
All right.
Oh, my...
I walked three steps.
I don't want to fight them because they took fucking forever.
They take fucking forever to kill.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It didn't take fucking forever.
Then I'd be fine.
All right.
Let's go back in.
Let's go here.
There's anything...
Oh, wait.
Mario!
I've been waiting for you!
This warp pipe will lead you straight to Peach's Castle!
Nice.
Okay.
That's what I needed.
Is there anything here, though?
Oh, that's true.
I could get...
I've never...
Okay.
I've never authentically encountered a Shiny in the wild before.
Like, I played Pokemon games since, um...
My very first Pokemon game was Crystal.
And since Crystal, I've never encountered a single Shiny in the wild.
I've only, like...
The only time I've ever got a Shiny in-game was when I had to, like, actually breed for it.
Hmm.
So the castle leads to one another!
I wonder if there's any point in heading the west to another one!
What the fuck?
Wait.
All of them just head here.
They all just head here!
Alright.
Get out of here.
My very first Shiny that I got was an Eevee.
Because I wanted the Shiny Sylveon.
Because Sylveon's, like, one of my...
Uh, well, Shiny...
I don't count Shiny Gyarados.
Because, like, it's not, like, a naturally...
It's, like, a story set, you know?
Like, everybody...
Everybody counters a Gyarados.
Have I ever been here before?
Mario!
Are you participating in a Cap Challenge?
If so, I think you may need this!
Yeah, I love Shiny Sylveon.
A lot.
I think they're, like, one...
It's, like, one of the better Shiny colors.
Uh, variants.
Because there are some really fucking shitty ones.
Like, I'm surprised Pikachu has such a shitty, shiny, alternative color.
Because it's, like, you know, it's, like, the...
Um, the, like, Pokemon mascot.
I think back then they weren't...
I mean, they could have, like, changed it.
I know they're, like, well, that's what he was like in the first Pokemon game.
But they can easily just change it.
What do you know about type advantages?
It doesn't matter.
If, as long as I'm stronger than you...
I don't even care about type advantages.
Oh my god, wait.
This is a problem.
He...
I say as he brings out a fucking Cheep Cheep.
Okay.
Um...
It's okay.
I'm still stronger.
I...
I love...
Look.
Oh, okay.
Thank god.
Okay.
That's okay.
Like I said, type doesn't matter, guys.
It doesn't matter.
No.
That didn't mean to buy a fish.
Beanie?
The fuck is...
Where did Beanie come from?
Which game is Beanie?
Oh my god.
He's a bean.
What the hell is Beanie?
It is...
It's the famous Beanie, Doki.
Superstar Saga?
More than I do, it seems.
Yeah, I brought a fucking Fire-type into a Water-type battle.
What's Superstar Saga?
There's so many Ant Troopers everywhere.
Don't worry.
I'll make sure the population become endangered.
Oh, it's an RPG game.
Oh!
I see.
I never played any of the RPG ones.
Oh, I paralyzed here.
I never grew up with them.
But I heard the...
I heard the Mario Brothers ones.
Like the Mario & Luigi ones are really good.
I just never grew up with them.
That's where I came from, right?
Yeah, it is.
We'll head here.
Go, Dad!
Go!
I never even...
I never even played Paper Mario.
Yeah, I never played any of the Mario RPGs.
Not even Paper Mario.
Because I never had a game...
I didn't have a GameCube growing up.
I had a GameCube when the lifespan was about to die.
And that was the only time I've ever had a GameCube.
I already went here.
I'm already lost.
I can't believe...
I'm at World 1-2 and I already forgot which way I've been.
Rogue, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Peach's Castle.
Alright!
Yay!
I'm gonna see my girlfriend!
Alright.
Yeah, guys.
Uh-huh.
I, Mario...
Can have a girlfriend.
And she's a princess.
Welcome, Mario!
Come to see a princess?
She's right up ahead!
Love fishing so much!
Oh, hey.
Nice.
I got a ride.
Oh my god.
You can get a Cheep Sheep.
Is Cheep Sheep like the Magikarp?
The Magikarp of Mario?
Let's see.
How do I...
Register.
Select.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, I'm gonna catch myself a Cheep Sheep.
Oh!
Oh my god!
It's Cheep Sheep!
Alright, we need a water type anyway, so this works.
Oh my god!
And he's level 5!
He's...
He's Cheep Sheep, but like...
He's Magikarp, but better!
Because he doesn't have only Splash...
Oh, I should have bought more Plumber Caps.
I can't believe like...
I have to pay for these.
Like this game that...
Um...
The princess is making me play.
And I just spend my own money on the materials.
Oh, this is bad.
Don't worry.
He'll live.
I believe.
Okay, this is a little...
Awkward.
But he'll live.
I believe.
Yeah, it's her way of increasing...
The economy.
I request to be Luffish.
Problem!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, you'll be Pragoon.
Yay!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
That's a little...
A little...
A little weak right now.
Pragoon.
A big Luffish.
Its wing-like fins allow it to leap out of the water to attack flying prey.
Okay, it frequents the water under bridges.
Oh my gosh, my floor.
I can feel it less.
I can feel it a bit sticky.
Coy.
No, my floor.
Both lips.
Someone's gonna have a good time.
Okay, uh...
Pragoon.
Hey, look.
He wants to be pro...
He wants to be a cheap...
Let him live his life.
I wonder if I can get another different type of fish.
Oh, a butt!
What kind of fish do I get?
Oh, it's the same one.
Okay, I'm leaving.
That is not okay right now.
I'm gonna leave.
Yeah, I was gonna think...
I thought...
I was thinking like...
Oh, it's because I have an old rod.
I really like to use Biddy Buddies.
They're my favorite.
I'm disappointed I can have only six of them at a time.
Your team looks rather tired.
Yeah, and they rest.
What is Mario gonna do with that fish, Toki?
Well, I'm missing...
I need like five more at first.
Now, princess love to use captures found around her garden.
I came from Saras Island.
They asked Princess Peach where Princess Daisy went.
Ever since the game started, she asked Bender...
What did you do to Daisy, Peach?
Where is Daisy?
Dixon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Toki.
Today is my birthday.
Have fun in the Easter holiday and keep going.
Thank you for the super chat, Dixon.
And because it's your birthday, don't worry.
I'll name Mario Mon after you.
And I'll exile you to the Goon Cave for your birthday present.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Dixon.
Yeah!
So, Harry.
I bet there's no sweat for you, Mario.
Yoshi!
Hey, Mario.
You can ride a Yoshi unless you have a Yoshi whistle to summon one.
Last I heard, someone in the Toe Town was giving them away.
Wait, really?
Nobody gave me a fucking Yoshi whistle.
Oh, if I catch a Yoshi, that's the guy.
I just need to catch a Yoshi.
Is there anything here?
Oh, nice.
I got a berry juice.
Dick Goon.
Very unfortunate name.
I just realized he's gonna be called Dick Goon.
I'm sorry.
Very unfortunate.
Oh, no.
My army of dragoons.
Very unfortunate.
Wait, why is it just an empty space?
Is there an invisible item here?
Oh my god, it's Beanie!
That's the perfect Dick Goon.
That shall...
I shall call him Dick Goon.
We got Beanie, guys.
No, I don't have it.
No, okay.
I have to use these.
We got the shift cap.
Just what we needed.
You get the...
The good...
His name is Richard Goon.
Dokey.
Robin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
An overgrown sentient bean.
His main method of attack is a trip-prone charge.
Its grinning face is a popular icon of local culture.
Alright, yes.
I wonder if I...
I should be able to name it because it's a ROM, right?
There's no way they...
There's no way they put limits on the ROM.
Just right.
My dick.
Oh, I knew it!
I knew it!
Surely...
Oh my god, it's allowed.
Wait.
How?
What else am I allowed?
Another rare cannon.
Let's see.
The system works, guys.
I want to see what the XP level...
Okay.
I went until I leveled up before I do it.
There's no fil...
There's no filters in the old games?
Not even one?
Okay, let's run.
I'm tired of grinding right now.
I need...
I don't have enough, like...
Stuff anyway.
Hey, it's Mario.
Do you know me?
Not yet, but you're about to.
My name is Frank Otto.
But you can call me Photo.
I like to take pictures of people playing the Cap Challenge.
Yes!
Take a picture!
Say cheese!
Now how about Super Mario Super Jump for the camera?
Oh!
Just go to my account...
Photocap.bsky.social...
Oh wait, it's on bluesky.
Peach's castles, where it all begins!
Okay.
Yoshi!
Princess Peach loves to have Yoshis around the castle.
Because we can be a bunch of different types.
Oh my god, are they the Yoshis?
Keep an eye out for the weird walks and the level details.
There might be an item hiding there.
Like, that one?
Wait, is the account actually real?
That's funny.
Alright, I'm gonna only fight the ones that I can kill easily.
All of them are like...
are like...
not effective against fire.
Oh nice, I got Super Shroom!
Alright, if they say the same thing, I'm not gonna repeat it.
I'm sorry, but this warp pipe is under maintenance!
Alright.
Makes sense.
I don't think there's anything here.
Oh wait, there's like...
a ledge here.
I think...
I don't think that goes.
That just goes backwards.
Alright, I'm gonna see my girlfriend!
Hello, my girlfriend!
I love you!
You're welcome, Mario!
I hope the trip from your house wasn't too long.
That's my girlfriend!
Where's Luigi?
I thought he would be with you.
No, no.
Let's not talk about my brother!
Peach?
I'm a hero, princess!
Oh my god, there he is.
Did I miss anything?
Fuck you, Luigi.
You're the reason why I spilled my iced tea.
It's always Luigi's fault.
Nothing at all.
You're right on time.
I believe today I built a team.
Of course, princess.
This is...
Here is Bitey, Chuck, and Private.
And we're gonna win the cap.
You're the reason why my mom's left.
And we're gonna win the cap challenge!
Whatever it may be!
What is it exactly?
This is a challenge to see who is the smartest, wisest, and kindest leader in all the world.
Oh, that's me!
I'm especially really kind.
Eight people from across the kingdom hold special power stars.
The first person to click all five will be granted a wish.
So it's a race!
To prepare you both, my guards have put together a special test so you both can understand the little complexity of this game.
Beat them all, and I'll reward you both for your first power star.
What do you say, bro?
Wanna test the...
No.
Sure!
You take one hallway.
I said no!
And I'll take the other.
Good luck to the...
Get away from me, Luigi.
This is what's supposed to be my special time with my girl.
My brother and I want to try to play together.
So we're ready to petition for siblings to act as the same commander.
No.
Oh, wait.
Shit.
I actually clicked yes.
Thank you, Mario.
God damn it.
I was smashed.
It, like, led me back to know.
Yes.
All right.
Wait, what does this go?
Did you see a Yoshi and the entire watermelon spit on the seeds?
Just like this!
I created TMs just so you're captured to try that, too!
Guys, I got peer pressure.
It always works.
Wait, what is it?
It was TM51.
Oh, yeah!
I feel just like...
Wait, is there a physical special split?
Or is this a type-based in this game?
All right.
Oh, it's a bullet seed?
Oh, that makes sense.
All right.
I go right, yeah?
Where does he go?
Oh, boy, oh, boy!
I get to be catamander, not a capture!
Ever since we started a cap challenge, the princess has become more active around the castle!
Oh, my gosh.
She actually does her job now?
You think the princess patched up the ultra shortcut through the garden?
Oh, there's a shortcut!
I'm sniffing out for the wish that the princess is offering.
What do you mean I'm a capture?
I don't think you can BLJ your winter princess this time!
Wait, what's BLJ?
Let me show you!
Okay.
Oh, is that the one where you have to mash the button?
In the...
What is that game called?
The Mario 64?
Yeah.
Is that the Mario 64 tech?
Wait, he has a speed boost?
How...
I'm already slow.
I fucking walk!
I'm a bomb!
But bomb is no run!
Oh, he's using Cheep Cheep.
Water types won't stop me!
Oh, he's level 6.
Okay.
Water types can't stop me!
That's right!
Get out of here!
I think I'm scared!
I don't need to use anybody else!
You'll live!
That's right!
I told you you'd live!
Always believe in him.
Hello to the other halfway to defeat the other challenge!
Alright.
Let me go...
Make sure he does not die.
Let me...
Let me make sure he's...
Let me make sure I, you know, restore his HP a little bit.
Yeah, he's fucking tough as shit.
Alright, let's go.
I didn't really calculate anything.
I just believed.
All you have to do is believe.
I'm trying to stock up as many items as I can!
No sharing!
I came to Peach's Castle in hopes of getting a job as a court shaman.
But Toad's return me down.
Why does he get to make so many cars?
Master Mario!
It seems like you have not finished your lesson!
Come back once you have completed it!
Wait, where did...
Alright.
You have to go here?
I've been using Taldex!
I got so much useful information!
Like showing what modes a capture can learn!
Alright, cool.
Oh, I went backwards.
Let me show you!
Okay, items changed how bad...
I also don't use items.
Unless it's like full restore.
Oh, wait.
What is Toad's worst voice?
Is he just like a normal man?
I thought all Toad's had like the same voice.
He just sounds old?
Okay.
That's easy.
Thank God.
Where's secrets?
Oh, flame charge!
Yes.
Actually.
Is it a power move?
Oh, it is.
Okay, we're gonna get rid of charge.
One, two, and poof!
We ain't learning no stats here.
Stat moves do not exist in my game.
Not all Toad's.
Oh my God!
It's Spike!
I want a Spike!
Wait, what type are you?
Oh my God.
And I'm strong too.
And I'm...
Oh my God.
I'm finally like...
I'm now doing a brisk walk.
Instead of just a walk.
Oh.
That's it?
That's like one damage.
Okay, it's not stopping.
Okay, you can stop now.
It's like...
It's just one damage.
He says as he fucking...
Chucks three more.
All right.
Berries are yummy.
Am I right?
Yes, Toad.
Berries are yummy.
All right.
Complete it both.
Let me...
Check this.
I want to talk to him.
Hey, Bits, are guarding it?
There's a bunch of strong captures there.
Where is the garden?
I assume the garden is deeper in the cast.
Wait, if it's...
I need to find a store.
Master Mario.
Swell job making it to me.
Here, let me heal your minds.
Your captures.
Now then, I believe we understand what is unfolding.
Mind you, I am no pushover.
So hope you have taken notes from your previous battles.
Wait, I have to fight an old man?
I have to fight a 40-year-old?
I'm sorry.
Shall we begin?
Gentleman Toads would like to battle.
I didn't come here to be...
Oh my god, it's a shy guy.
Wait, that's a little wrong.
Because like, at least like, they're humanoid shape.
What the fu- Oh, it's not very- Yeah, it's a bug move.
Yeah, like, he's- This is a little bit more wrong.
How queer.
I've been stabbed.
Wait, my controller DC'd.
Okay, there we go.
Now it's back.
Alright.
Use recharge.
Get in there.
And like, there it said, USB disconnected.
I was like, oh no.
Alright, send in another one.
Monty Mo- What's he gonna do?
Yeah, but they're toads.
Like, he doesn't have- Look.
Like, Koopas don't have the name- The word guy in it.
Yeah.
That was the strongest grass attack in the game.
Look, this is why we did not get- Per- Like, we did not get the piranha plant, guys.
Like, no matter what, grass type is always like, the weakest shit in the starters, I feel.
I feel like it's never worth it getting a grass type.
The only time I've ever, uh, picked up a grass starter was for, uh, Snivy.
That was the only time.
I mean, cause like, look at him.
Like, I mean, look at Sn- I mean, I think every- I think Snivy was like, the best looking one out of all the starters.
I was about to use Fang?
Wait, which one's Fang?
Oh!
It seems on my last legs.
Very well- Oh my god, look at him!
He's mostly eyes!
Oh, that's cute!
Oh my god, it's Legally Distinct Zubat!
Alright, goodbye.
Oh my god, he's level eight.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, it is- He's Zubat if he had eyes.
He took his eyes, guys.
I will not falter!
For the princess!
For Doki!
Next thing they give us Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, what do you think about Meow-Scarada?
Skarada?
Okay, I've- No, I haven't played a game where, like, those- I don't remember what the three starters look like.
I just- Uh, I know one looked like a cat.
Which was what Meow-Scarada was.
And, um...
I remember I saw a clip of, like, the cat, like, getting out of bed as if it's like- It's a person, so it's like- And then I was like, oh my god, that Pokemon just looks like she could pay rent.
Like, like, cause it's like- Cause it's like, you know, they're your pets, right?
But then, like, in the Pokemon anime, she just moves around as if, like, she was, like, a human person.
Like, in the bed.
And then it's like, I'm like, oh my god, at this point, she should pay rent.
You know, it would, like, she's, like, legally, like, basically, like, humanoid enough.
Well done.
Allow me to heal your party.
Yeah, she should be paying taxes.
Now then, the princess is waiting.
Talk to her and you will earn your first Power Star.
Oh my god, this is my first Shin battle!
Hello, princess.
Congratulations on completing the test.
I hope Toezeret didn't give you a rough time.
My sincerest apologies, princess.
For I was unable to defeat Master Mario and Master Luigi.
That's quite alright.
Now, on the topic of Power Starts, let's go, it's Mario- Oh, wait, is it Bowser?
Never mind, it's Bowser time.
What was that noise?
Oh my god!
It's Abracadabra!
I don't know his name.
Come back!
Ahem.
Introducing his royal highness.
The Scroogey Eyes and Nostros.
The king of the Koopas!
King!
Peach!
Peaches, peaches, peaches.
So I am an outcast again, huh?
What did I do to deserve it this time?
Shall I read off the list?
Can it blabby?
I've been on a good streak for a while now.
I haven't kidnapped you in how long?
Four days!
And I'm going through a trial.
I'm really trying here.
Right, and now, you're hosting this party and I'm not invited.
I have to hear about this from Junior.
You told his son and not him.
That's fucked up.
Imagine, like, your son knows about this and not you.
Junior!
You gave a power sword to my boy, Junior, instead of me?
That's actually really fucked up.
Oh my god, new perso fest.
A whole four days.
Alright, um, well, you see.
That's because you're a commander too.
You're one of the best commanders in the whole world.
Surely you have to find out yourself.
Princess, I don't think he's going to buy that.
Woohoo!
Give him a moment.
Don't worry.
He'd be like...
You finally admit how awesome and amazing my skills are?
Don't worry.
He's so, like, peach cord.
Like, he'd believe anything she'll say.
Alright, I'll play.
Let me gather my platoons and mop the floor of this party.
I'm sorry, but that's against the rules.
There are rules?
How was I supposed to know that?
But, sire, if I may interject.
You have...
You have the floor.
No need.
I'm already on it.
Toads were sent out pamphlets explaining how everything plays.
I've been reading it to the prince for bedtime.
Hand it over.
Yes, sire.
So you see here...
Only up to six...
Only up to six captures.
Explains here.
You see that rule?
I'm gonna choose to ignore it.
Sire, certainly you just...
Wait, how come he gets to have seven?
Imagine it brings, like, a hundred.
Too bad.
If that disqualifies me, then I win by my own means.
Oh my god, he's just like me.
For real, for real.
Mario, I'm gonna make an example out of you.
Be careful, bro.
Bowser can be plotting anything.
This is what happens when you don't invite me to your...
Wait, how does he have captures now?
He just got...
Did he just, like, bring out...
He, like...
Oh my god.
He, like, brought out, like, his men out here?
He just, like, dragged three from his army.
He's like, you!
Alright, get out of here.
Bowser, my husband.
And he still has a level three.
He just, like, picked one up from his army.
And you're like, wear this hat!
What?
That was, like, one hit!
No.
I'll dad you all.
Wait, that's...
Oh my god, wait.
What the fuck?
Toadie?
Who the fuck is Toadie?
Toadie!
Where did he come from?
He has a Doraemon helicopter.
That's a child.
Oh wait, is he flying type?
Oh, I've never played Yoshi Island before.
Alright.
Nice!
Thanks for helping me level up, Bowser.
I really appreciate it.
Alright.
What is he gonna send out?
Wait, did he send him himself?
Wait, what the fuck?
That's illegal.
You can just...
You can just do that?
No more playing!
Wait, can I catch Bowser?
Wait, it's not very effective?
What type are you?
Oh no.
I think he's ground type.
Don't worry.
Okay, wait.
No, I think...
Okay, I need a...
Oh, this is bad.
This...
This is bad.
Oh, this is bad.
I...
I don't have...
I don't have any...
Oh...
This is not good.
Oh no.
Oh wait.
Okay, he's weak.
He's weak.
Okay, we're fine.
I can...
It's fine.
As long as it doesn't get...
Okay, I'll use it when we're almost there.
When we're almost...
No, it's weak.
Fire is weak.
All right.
Don't worry.
I can take this.
I can take it all.
Go, Dad.
Go.
Keep taking it.
Okay.
I think...
I think it's time.
It's time.
Yippee!
No!
Did I just lose to my own minions?
It's time.
And I did it.
What?
But how?
I can go XP for that?
Go!
Next, you think it was a super chat that you think you...
Oh, I forgot.
I forgot.
Don't get XP.
You need to treat your party with love and affection.
I literally self-destructed my only strong mod.
But it was out of love.
No, I think it's because he doesn't know how to play yet.
I don't recall asking you, Green Sash.
And I can play perfectly fine.
I just need to get some training in.
Yeah, that's it.
Since Kaman knows this game by the book already, he's gonna be my cap challenge tactician.
This is the last time you've seen a me.
Mark my words.
Your wish will be mine, Peach.
Bah-ha-ha.
Kaman, lift yourself off the floor.
We got some scheming to do.
Yes, my liege.
All right, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Toadsworth?
Yes, Princess?
Junior?
Princess, this party was hastened effort.
I won't decide to exclude Bowser and Kamek.
Let's have a discussion about that later.
Don't worry, Princess.
We'll get the Power Stars before Bowser does.
I know you both will.
Which reminds me, you still need the Power Star from the Mushroom Kingdom.
There's only one more battle you need to win to get there.
That's right.
You hold the Mushroom Kingdom Power Star.
I'll only fight one of you at a time.
So decide who wants to challenge me first.
Hey, bro.
I'm still a little shaken from Bowser.
So you can fight the princess first.
Yeah.
I'll heal your captures too.
All right, time to...
Time to kill the princess.
Show her that I'm a man.
That's-a me, Mario.
I am Princess Peach of the Mushroom Kingdom.
And I accept your challenge.
That's our bro.
All right.
You saw what I did.
You knew that I showed no mercy.
Let's see how you handle the star leader.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
I love her.
I love her like pixel art.
All right.
Get out of here.
That's a bug type.
I ain't no afraid of no bug.
Wait, that's not a bug type?
Wait, what type are you?
But you look like a bug.
Yeah, the sprites are really good.
That's also what I miss.
And like...
Is this a fairy type?
Because he's using...
Is it normal?
But he's like a ladybug.
But this is what I miss about the newer Pokemon games.
That they don't do like...
They don't do pixel art anymore.
And like the 3D models are so boring.
Especially animations.
Oh wait, baby Yoshi?
What does a baby Yoshi look like?
Oh my
little chungus boy.
He's not gonna be such...
He's just...
He looks like he definitely...
He's not there.
He's not there mentally right now.
Yeah, why is his eyes like that?
Oh, is this a normal type gym?
Oh my god.
I want a baby Yoshi.
Bro is eating...
Yo, bro is...
Bro is ordering Wendy's at 4 in the morning right now.
Okay, this is bad.
The baby Yoshi is sort of kicking my ass.
But he's a baby!
Oh, this is bad.
Don't worry.
I can live for one more.
One more hit.
And then I'll eat a berry.
I'll be fine.
Okay.
Let's see.
I should have like an extra berry.
20 HP.
Okay, I have berry juice.
Alright, get in there.
The others will not survive.
The others...
They're not gonna make it.
You're...
Oh wait, there's a mushroom here.
Oh, the mushroom heals too!
Oh.
Alright.
Any tackle will be better?
I thought flame charge is a stronger move.
Alright.
I don't want to waste my thing.
Oh my god.
That was so much XP.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Crazy D.
Oh, I can...
I can one-shot him.
La la la la la la.
I believe.
Okay, but like how much do I believe?
This is a 50-50 right now.
Do I...
He looks like a grass type.
What's up?
Okay.
I was like, okay, do I risk it?
Do I...
I don't need to...
I was like, this is an actual gamble right now.
What's that?
Oh, it's not that bad.
Alright, nice.
It wasn't that bad.
Alright, get in there.
I only got one move and it's flame charge.
Oh, I...
Okay.
Oh no.
I'm already asleep.
That's fucking right.
Stupid.
I'm already asleep.
It's okay.
I can't tank that.
It's not okay.
It's okay.
I have another mushroom.
Guys, I cannot keep blowing things up, guys.
I need to actually...
Guys, my strat cannot just be blowing things up.
I actually need the XP.
I...
Wake up!
No!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm not risking it.
I'm not...
Please.
Please wake up, dad!
Wake up!
How are you still asleep?
How?
Oh my god.
You woke up.
I should have used charge.
God damn it.
I thought...
I thought I wouldn't wake up.
It's okay.
I did not want to send my other mons out.
Yay!
I should have leveled up.
I'm level 14!
Oh my god.
Nappy time over.
Okay.
That is like...
Guys.
These stats do not look...
These stats are actually like...
A glass cannon right now.
Like...
If I kill everything...
Then it will be fine.
As long as I kill everything...
It will be fine.
If they don't hit me first...
Then it should be okay.
Yeah.
We're just here to one shot.
Don't need HP if everything dies.
Oh, did I lose?
Yay!
A thousand dollars for my girlfriend.
Oh my god!
Dad's evolving!
What if I just stopped it?
I was like...
No!
Yay!
What did he evolve to?
What do you look like?
What the fuck is that?
Is this a bomber man?
Chuck Yaw?
I should have stopped it.
Alright, shit.
What are you?
What do you have?
Where did your legs go?
Where did you...
Oh, is it from Mario 64?
Where did your legs go?
I should have hit B.
Where did your foot...
No!
He's fighting!
It's fire fighting!
No!
Fire fighting, Chris.
You can never escape fire fighting.
No!
Wow, even in Super Mario Kart, the firefighting curse continues every time.
Mario, you see the Mushroom Kingdom Power Star.
You can never escape.
With this Power Star, you'll be able to rally and motivate higher level teammates.
On top of that, I'd like to give you something that could help your team out.
Oh, nice.
A TM that I'll never use.
Mario, put away.
What I just give you is a training module, or TM for short.
It's a video that teaches your creatures how to use special moves.
This one is called Charm.
I have one more thing for you.
Hold on just a moment.
Oh, it's my Power Star!
Oh, it's a Yoshi egg!
Here, Mario.
Take this Yoshi egg.
I think that you'll raise them well.
Oh my god, I got a Yoshi egg!
Yeah!
Okay, Luigi.
Now it's your turn.
Are you ready?
Ready as I ever be, princess!
I'll catch up with you later, Mario.
Alright, goodbye.
Can I watch?
Alright, bro.
Wish me luck!
Okay, that's the castle.
Okay, I need a...
Is there a store near me?
Do I have to go all...
Oh my god.
Alright, guys.
I need to go all the way back to...
Uh, to the town.
Because I...
Yeah...
Fuck!
Oh, I don't have any more caps!
God dammit!
I wanna catch...
I wanna catch some...
He said there was like a lot of really cool mons.
In the...
Princess castle...
Gardens.
You have to...
Go buy some caps.
I'm glad I copped to you, Master Mario.
Here, I have some gadgets just arrived from Professor E.
Gag.
Oh my god.
Finally, Mother Mons can actually be strong.
The PSS...
What's the piss?
The first device will distribute XP to even party members that don't participate in battle.
Oh, you can also turn it off and on as you please.
The second device will allow you to access the capture storage network from wherever you please.
Oh!
Press the art button while viewing your current button.
Oh, that's so convenient!
I say...
What does he mean by an art button?
Oh, that's actually...
So convenient!
I can literally...
It should be fully operational by now.
I can just like replace my mods whenever I want.
Oh my god, that's like the original one from Pokemon.
I love that one.
You can use it to return to Toad Sound, Warp Zone, Post Ace.
From there, I believe the Warp to World 2 should be open for you to continue on your journey.
Best of luck, Master Mario!
Alright, let's go buy some caps and go steal some...
Steal some henchmen for my team.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, are these like...
Oh!
I see!
Those are all the portos.
Okay, let's get...
How many can I get?
30?
Fuck it, let's spend it all.
Yeah.
I don't need anything else.
Alright!
What is my...
Are they full HP now?
Oh no, they're not.
I have to heal.
Okay, let me heal real quick.
Wait, that's not the healers.
Yeah, so like, I can...
That's where it's...
Like, it takes me to each world, I believe.
Alright, let's go to Peach's World.
It's pink, just like Peach.
Oh, I had to grab my Yoshi!
Where was it?
Uh...
How did I grab it?
It's in my pockets, right?
Oh, and then Rare Candy, too.
Alright.
Oh no, it's in it!
It's already in!
I already have it.
While the curse of firefighting got you, there's still a chance that Dad could evolve into the king of the bombs.
Oh my god, please.
Please, I...
I don't want firefighting.
Rogue, thank you for the super chat!
I think it's the...
I can't!
Please!
Break that curse!
Oh yeah, I should.
I should give him my XP.
Wait, guys!
With the XP share?
Um...
Does it mean it takes less XP from my...
Oh wait.
Does it take less XP from, like, my...
My main...
From Dad?
Or...
Um...
Does it distribute it?
Does it not?
I need to know.
That's important.
Okay, okay.
Because if it does, I'll turn it off.
It shouldn't?
Okay, that's good.
Oh my god, it's Beanie again.
Wait, I already...
I thought they said I'll get rare mons.
I fucking gave me Beanie.
Alright, get out of here, Beanie.
We already have one.
Nice.
Is that evenly?
Okay, I just don't want it...
I just don't want it to, like...
Uh...
Oh my god, everybody's actually finally getting fed now.
You know, like...
It's like, please...
Can I please...
Can you please...
Oh, you ready to hatch?
That's so fast!
No, like...
I'm just gonna name you...
I'm gonna name you Regular Dragoon.
Alright, this...
He gets to be...
Just a Dragoon.
He'll be all of you.
You all get to be him.
You all get to be Dragoon.
Okay.
It's you guys!
Guys, it's you!
We are all Yoshi!
What the fuck is that?
Okay...
Nippers...
Let me use Spark.
I'm scared I'm gonna, like, destroy him.
That's me!
There you guys are!
See?
Everyone can be...
Everybody can be...
Can be a Dragoon.
Alright, nice.
Oh, that's good.
I can catch you.
Where's my Pokeballs?
Alright, there is...
Caps.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
A baseball cap.
Oh, it's a higher...
No, we're not using any of that.
We're only using plumber caps.
Alright, nice.
Husky!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This one, whatever is first found in the...
Okay.
You get to be a husk goon.
Nice.
He should have named you.
That's simple.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Finally, you are fed.
My goons.
You can all be fed now.
Oh my god.
They're all like...
Thank you, Toki, for finally feeding me.
I was so hungry.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my god.
He's still leveling up.
A tiny little plant is known to walk around, leap into the air, and even breathe fire.
It does this to protect itself while it's still in its infancy.
Nom nom nom nom.
Alright.
Let's see.
Husk.
Wait, can I do husky?
Or is that...
H-U-S-K-Y-G...
Oh, I can!
Nice.
H...
U...
S...
K...
Oh.
Oops.
Y...
T-O-O-N.
There you go.
Alright.
Exiled into the...
Wait, actually...
Where's the R button?
Wait, what?
How do I...
Wait, how do I...
How do I open this?
Where's my R button?
Okay, clearly...
I don't think I have my R button registered.
I'll just do that.
Alright.
E-gags.
Okay.
I wanna know like...
Alright.
This is...
What are my types?
What do I have in here?
Alright.
Dick Goon?
I'm sorry.
But I'm uncomfortable.
I'm gonna put a plan in here.
I'll put...
I'll put a...
I'll put a husky goon.
Alright.
I'm sorry, little guy.
I'm uncomfortable.
Are you in the party?
No...
No beanies allowed.
Sorry.
I can't...
I don't want any beans in my...
In my team.
Hey guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tim's on the...
The ghost.
Alright guys.
It's all...
Russian Roulette.
It's randomized.
You don't get to pick which one.
It's like...
You get chosen.
You don't have a choice.
But you get chosen.
Um...
P, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dips to be a bullet.
If you catch one.
Don't worry if you're lucky.
Oh wait.
Dragon.
Wait.
Bubble.
Um...
I'll put a tail whip.
Oh my god.
It has like a little...
The sound effect too.
Dragoons are in bubble.
It's destiny.
That's right.
Whatever you get is your destiny.
On his birthday.
I exiled Diggoon.
Look.
It's not my fault.
That the first...
Mario mod.
I encountered.
Was Beanie.
Look guys.
How is that my fault?
What?
Wait.
Send out the baby Yoshi.
It's got a funny back sprite.
Okay.
I'll see what it looks like.
Uh...
Read.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Justice for Diggoon.
Alright.
Let's see.
I wonder how I can...
Cause it's gonna be...
It's like the Eevee.
Right?
I wonder how...
Alright.
How does it look like?
How does this baby look like?
Before he dies?
Oh my god.
It's a bull!
I'm a little uncomfortable.
What if I flash?
Use flash!
Oh my god.
No.
Don't look at me like this.
You were bored like...
30 minutes ago.
Don't look at me like that.
And don't...
Oh my god.
Let's do the cinema.
Me.
Oh no.
That's you, by the way, chat.
That's you.
Aphelia, thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you.
You're welcome, chat.
Alright.
Please tell me.
No!
I killed him!
You know, it's for the best.
It's for the best.
We saw things today.
Bro's got the smug look of superiority.
Azura, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Uh...
Kuma, if you catch the boo, name it, man.
Well...
She's dead.
What the fuck is that?
Oh my...
Kill it!
Oh, I forgot you were in first up.
Oh, I forgot all about it.
Oh my god.
What?
Yep.
That's the way dragons.
Look at Toki.
Not so dead.
Put him away.
I forgot you were the first one.
Alright.
There's no way I one shot this guy, right?
Okay, nice.
I didn't first kill him this time, guys.
I did it.
I did the bare minimum.
Wait.
Who was the one that was like...
Let's see.
Dibs on the ghost?
Alright.
Hey, guys.
Don't worry.
You get something better.
Sprangler.
Don't worry.
Alright.
A large stripy spider.
It hangs from ceilings by a thread of strong webbing.
It swings back and forth like a pendulum in order to disorientate its prey.
You got something even better than a boo.
Hey, good.
I told you.
Whatever you get is your destiny.
Hey, good.
Alright.
Nice.
Exiled.
As it should be.
As...
Oh, you're right.
Okay.
If we catch a boo, we'll name it a whisper goon.
Oh my god.
You're so right.
Why is there so many nips here?
Oh my god.
I need a...
Okay, we're running.
I need to fix my...
I need a...
I don't...
I can't.
Get back.
Get back at my sixth slot.
What?
You get...
You're in the...
You're bounding to the sixth slot.
Little guy.
I can't...
I can't have him there.
Alright, get up.
Look at that face.
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yay.
Level 8.
Champion, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can I get dibs on the next unique one?
What do I name...
If I catch the sprangler, you get to be sprangler too.
Aw...
You get saved.
One ticket for the isekai.
Gotcha, please.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, Papa.
If I...
If I catch this beanie, you get to be beanie too.
Oh.
I might be able to catch this one.
Very risky request.
And then I shall banish you.
Alright.
Not again.
Smurf goon.
Yay.
Level 10.
But they said unique.
No, this one said isekai.
Gotcha.
Oh.
You get to be a smurf.
You get to join.
You get to join dick goon too.
Oh my god.
Where did I put you both in the daycare center?
And make more beanies.
Oh.
And then I can name more beanie children.
I can name more beanie children.
Guys.
Sound.
Why are they all nips?
I want it.
I want a boo.
That's your gotcha.
John.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can you name the ugliest one after me, please?
John.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys.
I accidentally unplugged my controller.
Because I was like twirling it.
Oh no.
It's not red.
Guys.
It's not registering.
No.
My controller.
I was twirling my controller.
Then the USB fell out.
Controller.
Please.
My Xbox One controller.
I can't progress.
No.
Wait.
Can I save?
Oh no.
Guys.
I fucked up.
I can't move it.
Oh no.
Okay.
Wait.
Settings.
Keyboard.
Oh, it's Z in it.
Okay.
Alright.
I know how to do the.
Do it on PC.
Yay.
Okay.
Guys.
I can't move it.
Oh no.
How do I do the main menu?
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Um.
I need to look at my controls on keyboard.
I don't know my keyboard controls.
Uh.
Keyboard.
A.
S.
Backspace.
Return.
Okay.
Backspace.
Oh wait.
That's not it.
Where's return?
I don't have a return key.
I have to rebind that.
Settings.
Keyboard.
Um.
I'll use...
Wait.
I do.
Return is my enter key.
Oh my god.
I'm so stupid.
Return is my...
Okay.
Wait.
Why?
Okay.
Wait.
There we go.
Yes.
Tokyo.
Mario.
Saving.
Yeah.
Alright.
I gotta restart my game.
I gotta restart it.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
GBA.
I had to restart it because I accidentally fucked up.
I accidentally unplugged my controller because I was twirling it.
Alright.
Give me a boo.
Why are they all spranglers?
They're so ugly.
Get me out of here.
I don't want no sprangler.
Only spranglers and nips.
I don't know.
I didn't know we were playing by Genie wishes.
There was Papa Smurfs.
Thank you.
That's super...
Oh shit.
Oh I got bite.
Okay.
We don't need...
We don't need Flash, despite how much I would have loved...
With the face he was making.
It's just all Spranglers.
I literally saw one Boo and that's it.
This is so messed up.
How was I supposed to know I could just kill him?
Jen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You should name the best looking one after John.
Also, we're not playing by Genie Wish's rule.
It's the monkey paw rule.
You want a name...
You want a name in the...
In the doki party?
You don't get to decide who your mod is.
Oh my god!
There was only one Boo that lives in her garden?
I can't believe the Boo was so rare in Cali.
I'm so sad.
There was only one and you killed it.
The monkey paw curl.
How was I supposed to know he could just die?
Alright.
There has to be.
I won't leave until I get that Boo.
God damn it.
They're all beanies.
It's either boonies, nips, and Spranglers.
Peach has a fucking pest control problem.
At least I don't have to voice act some toads.
We do not leave until we get a Boo.
I don't know.
I thought like...
You know...
I thought it'd work.
Oh my god.
I used Spark though.
That's a weak move.
I thought, you know...
Spark is like super weak.
All right.
It's fine.
There should be one more Boo.
Oh my god.
It's just all beanies.
Please.
One singular Boo in the army.
Oscar, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry.
If I find another Magikarp, I'll name it after you.
Oh my god.
It's...
I've like given up fighting them.
They're like not even worth my time.
I've actually...
I've given up fighting these fuckers.
It's not worth my time at all.
It's...
Also, what the fuck is the art button?
Oh!
No!
I don't...
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I didn't want another...
I didn't want another one.
All right.
It was that.
It was...
That was the art button.
Oh my god.
They're all just...
I didn't know Boo's were the rare one.
Why is it so dirty that you immediately kill Milk Mint the moment you see her?
I swear to god, if there are rare encounters on the other...
In like other places after I tried so hard getting a Boo in her stupid fucking garden, I swear to god.
If it's like the ghastly situation where I just have to go somewhere else and go to like a haunted area, I swear to fucking god.
I swear.
But this is where I found Boo last time.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I was so excited.
Typical.
Thank you, man.
Super chat.
Thank you.
There is a Boo mansion?
Goodbye.
That's all I need to know.
I'll find a Boo in another time.
Goodbye.
I leave now.
Oh yeah, I wanted to...
What do I want to do?
I wanted to...
Oh yeah.
Check the Yoshi.
Which one is the...
Okay.
Nips.
Sprangler.
Peenie.
Baby Yoshi.
Where's the evolution thing?
Evo.
Level one up to 50.
Oh, yellow shell.
Wait, but what's the 50?
Oh, I guess 50 is the regular green Yoshi.
I want a yellow Yoshi.
Where is yellow Yoshi?
Is yellow Yoshi electric type?
Do you guys hear that?
Wait, 50 is Big Boy?
Guys, we're doing...
Guys, we're leveling with this one up to 50.
Guys, wait, what type is Big Boy?
What type...
Guys, okay.
I am okay to get spoiled for Big Boy.
I...
Big Boy is my favorite Yoshi.
It is my favorite Yoshi.
We need to be big.
Alright.
Yoshi's gonna be level 50.
My Big Boy.
Then you're in the right place.
Wait, but how come...
Where do I go?
Wait, what?
Where else do I go?
Orange pipe?
No one let me earlier.
Wait, oh, is this it?
Oh, I didn't realize it was next to me.
I thought this was like...
Hey, bro.
Oh, I finally...
The one that pipe I didn't look at.
I finally got up to you.
Mario.
Let's have a friendly battle.
But we're hitting the world too.
I want to show you how strong my captures I've been getting.
Oh, my God.
He has three months.
He has Chuck.
That's all right.
I have dad.
Hi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm gonna chuck you out.
You're gonna...
Your name is Chuck.
Watch me chuck you.
Whoa!
I'm firefighting.
Yeah.
Get Chucked.
All right.
40 more levels to go.
Don't worry.
I still have dad.
Oh, Bitey.
Oh, you're gonna...
Yeah?
I learned my mistakes.
Get out.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
You're still alive.
Oh, my God.
What will Bitey do?
Is he gonna bite me?
Oh, wait.
He did.
But it's not very effective.
That's fucking right.
Get Flame Charge.
That's right.
Get out of here, Bitey.
I learned my lesson.
I learned my lesson from our first fight, guys.
Never again.
Never again will I...
Will I self-destruct.
Flame on.
Oh, my God.
We're all getting stronger.
Look at all these other mods that I'm never gonna use.
Who's private?
All right.
Is it Koopa?
Oh, I fucking knew it.
So generic, Luigi.
I don't know if I can win, but I'm gonna give it my all.
How the fuck did you beat Princess Peach with this team?
That's it.
I bet you she gave you a pity start.
There's no way you beat Princess Peach with that team.
There's no fucking way.
Okay.
Vital throw.
Spirit with the power of friendship.
All right.
Get out of here, private!
Yay!
All right.
Oh, I got Flame Wheel.
Wait, what's that?
What does that look like?
Fire, charge, and may inflict burn.
Oh, my God.
All my moves are so good.
Guys, we can't get rid of self-destruct.
That should be, like, our boat, like, our actual, like, Hail Mary.
Oh, I don't know.
Really?
Do I really need...
Okay, you're right.
Me.
But it's my signature move.
Fine.
I'll get rid of self-destruct.
I almost want to fight with it.
Six.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
But it's so much fun, though.
It's the core of their identity.
His name...
He's literally a ba-bomb.
What kind of ba-bomb doesn't know self-destruct?
I'm not surprised.
I didn't win this time, bro.
You're always super good at party games.
That just means I need to find some more friends to train up.
I'll catch you later.
I can't believe it.
He lost his identity.
What kind of ba-bomb doesn't know self-destruct?
What would his mom think?
Wow!
We're so high up.
I may be careful not fall off so I don't cause any troubles for the lockatoos.
Oh, we're up in the sky.
Oh, they're gonna have flying type here, right?
I want to see.
I want to see the flying type.
Oh my god.
What are these...
What are these lips?
Alright, how strong am I?
Oh, nice.
Just in time.
Boom.
Alright.
Good.
I need to stop doing that.
I can just press R.
He's here to blow.
Because he's a clown, guys.
He's blowing the wind.
He's a clown.
Who was the one that was like, you should name the best looking one after...
Wait.
Wait, what was it?
Someone was like...
Oh, the ugliest one?
But then...
But he's not ugly.
He's beautiful.
A breezy fellow that hides itself in the clouds.
It attacks by creating freezing fogs.
But that can easily...
Oh, he's a fairy?
Alright.
John Goon.
You know what your job is.
Oh my god.
And it's female, too.
I don't think I want...
I don't think...
Oh, it's a pity bun!
I don't think I want John Goon in my party.
Don't worry.
All the...
All the Mario mons in Exile are gonna have a good time.
Baby doll eyes.
Oh, no.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
I don't know.
Not nice.
I accidentally killed him.
I might have to use like my other mons.
Oh, it's a spiny!
Hey, what type is spiny?
Okay, I can't kill...
Wait, okay.
I don't think this can kill spiny.
There's no way.
I want a spiny!
Nice.
If it's normal...
I might not be able...
Oh, it's seal?
Okay, nice.
I want spiny in my party.
I love spiny.
It's solid snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
In before Doki makes another smasher pass with balance.
Nuffy from Mario.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
God, thank you for...
No!
Get in my ball!
Or my cat!
Oh, but he's weak as fuck.
Okay.
I won't put you...
I might not put spiny in my party.
Because he seems like...
He's weak as hell.
So...
I don't think I need a seal type though.
I don't know.
I feel like...
Okay.
Honestly...
I'll take him over.
Oh, wait.
Spawn.
What did I get?
Bite?
Clamp.
I'll get rid of tackle.
He's level 11.
Give him a chance!
All right.
I'll see if he has better moves later.
A compact turtle with a spike shell.
Its slow speed makes it easy to manage.
Unless your preferred method attack is a stomp to the head.
All right.
What should...
Who would be spying me?
Hmm.
This is gonna be in my party.
So, like...
I'm test run.
Actually, he's gonna be test run.
So, like...
Might not necessarily be forever in my party.
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick though.
Before I decide.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Blow my nose before I start the game.
Before I go back to the game.
Oh.
There you go.
All right.
Who gets to be the lucky goon?
The lucky goon to be Spawny.
Spawny, Alan, Byte, Pottleball, Krish, and Foa.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
Let me look at the choices.
All right.
Let us get...
Hmm.
Me.
All right.
Gotcha time.
I'll give it to...
Hmm.
All right.
Let's see.
One roll on the gacha, please.
All right.
Helfito.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
You get to be my trial run.
For Spawny.
Where's F?
Okay.
Hey.
Hef...
Lee...
Hef-lee-goon.
Because I don't have enough space.
Would be fucked up if I spelled your name wrong.
It was placed in...
Don't worry.
I'll get you out.
How come I can't use the...
Don't worry.
I'll get you out of the Excel box.
Key items.
How come it...
The art doesn't work.
Oh.
In the party menu.
I'll do it here.
I hope John-goon...
I hope everybody's having fun with John-goon.
I...
I hope y'all having fun there.
All right.
Who are you...
Goodbye, tips.
You've had your good run.
But I don't want to rock Pokemon.
Come on.
We are.
All right.
Let's see.
I'm done.
All right.
Let's see.
What is my...
Oh yeah.
What is the type?
I didn't look at the type.
Steel.
Okay.
Wait.
Is he...
Spying?
All right.
All right, guys.
Let's see what other mons are in here.
What other mons are up in the sky?
Oh, it's just foo.
Another one.
Guys, do you think...
Do you think John needs more help?
Should I...
Should I have another helper over here?
Doki, please.
All right.
I just want to know...
I just want to see if there's any more.
Oh yeah.
I wanted to get Biddy Bud.
That's what I wanted to get.
Okay.
There's no way I'll fucking kill him right away.
Oh, it failed?
Oh.
There's no way I one-shot this guy.
Yeah.
There we go.
Nice.
Biddy Bud.
Get in my cap.
Yeah.
All right.
Next goon.
All right, Alan.
You get to be a Biddy Bud.
Don't worry.
You get to...
John's there.
A quaint round creature.
It has a strong sense of routine.
Its distinct bumbling sounds inspire folk music and help locals fall asleep.
All right.
Alan goon.
Alan...
Goon.
There we go.
Exiled.
All right.
That's all.
The doctor here is a little eccentric.
Don't get me wrong.
He'll kill you with any issues.
Just...
Don't let him creep you out.
Wait.
What's wrong with him?
All patients are subjected to experimental treatment.
I love experimental treatment.
Oh.
It's a shy guy.
A visitor.
Please.
Go see the doctor.
He'll help you out however he can.
Trust me.
What's this?
You have your party here?
Great.
This won't hurt a bit.
Probably.
Okay.
Never mind.
I take it back.
If it's a shy guy, I don't really want him near me.
What?
Oh!
Okay.
You definitely don't want to be in the line of fire when that happens.
Trust me.
Oh, wait.
You guys were like saying I should get in the line of fire.
Hmm.
Wait.
There's a latika.
Do you know what this switch here does?
Um.
You can tell me before you fight me.
Interviewed Nimbus.
We like to battle.
Oh, it's another.
Oh, you have one too?
In your own party?
Or latikusar.
Oh, you have...
It's in your own...
You brought...
Travel size.
Everyone has a foo.
What do you mean?
All right.
Let's bring...
Actually, no.
Let's not bring anybody out.
Toki, please.
You have two.
What do you have two?
Sir?
Why do you have two?
He gets...
Look, it's hard work out there.
Whoa!
I don't think that doctor...
Yeah, I don't think so.
I don't think it was a super...
Oh, wait.
It's red.
Maybe there's red mons.
Oh, no.
It's just the same guy.
God.
Guys, I think I get tired.
Okay.
No, it should be three foos and three cheep cheeps.
Yeah, I'll be the same, guys.
You gotta have variety.
The ideal cop.
Oh, it is red.
Wait, you're right.
It is red.
Red grass reads red mons.
All right.
I want to see if there's any other different ones.
Oh, no.
They're all just bitty buds.
All right.
Get out of here.
Get out of here, bitty bud.
The lips party.
What if I make my entire party?
The lips.
Oh, wait.
This one was already...
I want to see what's over here.
Did someone finally hit the switch?
Can I finally escape here?
Please tell me how you got here.
All right.
Let's keep him back in here.
Wait.
Is there any green mons?
What do the green mons look like?
Oh, no.
It's just another bitty bud.
God damn it.
Get out of here.
Nobody likes you.
Sorry, Alan.
Not sorry.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, my God.
There's so many foos here.
Actually, I'll kill one...
Oh, I actually killed him.
Not green.
What's the point?
Oh, my God.
It's literally just bitty buds.
Wait.
Can I fight you?
I mentioned to work out my pitching arm.
But nothing here is doing a trick.
Can you help me out?
Sure.
What do I do?
Perfect.
Let me just...
Oh, wait.
He's just going to chuck me.
Oh, I'm here now.
Still got it.
Okay.
That would have been unfortunately missed.
Oh, I got a metronome.
Is that TM?
Or...
Oh, no.
It's an item.
Excuse me.
You have to get the...
Don't study.
No, desert from here.
All right.
Desert goer Loretto.
Oh, yes.
Pokey.
That's cute.
Oh, it's a held item.
As long as you say...
Oh, wait.
That's me.
Wait.
I should give metronome to that.
I just used fire charge.
That's like my go-to.
Yeah.
All right.
What moves...
Okay.
Delete move from spikes.
What is this?
No, we don't need that.
That's for that competitive gaming.
We ain't no competitive gamer here.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, you're licking.
That's right.
You're gonna lick all the things.
Yeah.
Don't...
Spice are for nerds.
That's right, Dracoon.
I'll make sure you lick everything.
You know what?
Let me send you out.
How bad can it be?
Wait, that's a person.
Wait.
All right.
Lick him.
That's right.
Oh, it's not very effective.
All right.
That's...
That's all I wanted to do.
I sent you out.
Just threw you to lick him.
There we go.
Your job is done.
Your...
That's his entire job.
Nice.
Critical hit.
Why is Yoshi looking like that?
Why is FABY Yoshi looking like that?
You forgot one important part.
Pops out of a cap.
Licks you.
Leaves.
All right.
Nice.
Found a super shroom.
Oh, God.
Yes, now you know.
Okay.
Oh, that's my dem.
Check out what I managed to get hold of.
Yeah?
I swear to God.
If it's a food toad, I swear to fucking God.
Oh, it's a bullet bill.
Oh, if I sat in front of it, I'd fight him.
Wait, what is...
What is bullet bill's type?
He's my type, dude.
Yeah.
All right.
Nice.
Is this steel?
Oh, fuck.
Fuck.
Okay.
I actually like spiky more than bullet bill.
I mean, it's a bullet.
All right, Mr. Smartass.
He could be...
He could have flying as well.
It's a...
God damn.
Stop.
Stop sending me...
Stop sending bitty buds.
Can I be pew pew?
Silent Snake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We'll see what fate gets you guys.
Oh my God.
I keep hurting myself.
Dad, please.
Please.
Stop beating yourself up.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, nice.
Okay, it's 102.
Yippee!
All right.
Uh...
How do I activate this?
Here?
Oh.
Oh, it's another spiny.
Okay, I don't need it.
I don't need another spiny.
Oh.
I was like...
Yippee!
Your chest.
Uh...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'll be able to kill it.
So I should swap.
All right.
Who is like...
All right, Husky.
This is it.
This is your time to shine.
Your job is to weaken him.
All right.
You're getting punched.
But that's...
Okay, that's good.
He can't punch a...
You can't punch a plant.
Oh.
Oh, that's fine.
He's weak as fuck.
He can't punch a plant.
But you can cut it, though.
Which is a little worrisome.
Oh, okay.
It's fine.
If you die, it's okay.
You did your job.
Yeah, you can't punch a bug.
Actually, you can.
Wait, never mind.
Oh, please.
Please.
I just need...
Okay, nice.
Got my plumber cap.
Bullet Bill should have the move where he just shoots a gun.
Like, he shoots like...
He pulls out a miniature gun and shoots miniature versions of himself.
Yay!
A living bullet.
It is a simple-minded and is rarely changes its ways.
It does not usually reproduce.
Instead, new ones are born from a Bill blaster.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, so like...
They can.
They just don't.
They...
They just choose not to.
So...
All right.
Okay, who should it be?
Oh, this is a natural good one, too.
All right.
Solid.
You got the good one.
You actually got the 0.1% chance of actually getting what you want.
Solid.
Goon.
The 0.1%.
Gotcha.
But you're still exiled.
And you get to be in the box with...
With John?
That's a win-win right there.
You got everything you've ever wanted.
I think I got all the encounters there, too.
That's the...
I'm going to see the warp pipe!
I didn't manage to finish reading.
Hiker Sirius would like to battle.
All right.
Here we go.
Yay!
Oh, nice.
Oh, yeah.
Because it's steel.
And fire is good against steel.
Oh, it's brawler?
All right.
You know what?
Who is water type again?
Okay, pro-goon.
Pro-goon.
This is it.
I'm finally using type advantage for the first time.
Because I think if I don't...
Dad's gonna die.
It's your time to sh...
Oh, my God.
You're so fucking weak.
Okay.
We're replacing you later.
We're...
If I didn't know, you could have lived.
When you give him a chance, he's gonna almost die to his...
To his count...
Like, to the count that he count is.
It's not his fault.
Brody was just super tanky.
Okay, Buzzy B.
Yes.
All right.
Back to that.
I knew it.
Never swap off your main guy.
Never swap off your starter.
Doesn't matter if he's, like, hanged by the thread.
Never swap off.
Level him then.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
It's not very effective.
That's good.
Level him?
What does that mean?
Never swap off your carry.
Exactly.
Starter?
Yes.
He's my starter and he's the ender.
Exactly.
Hey, do you want to know how these bullet launchers work?
Yeah, sure.
All you gotta do is go up to them, interact with them like this.
Then, boom.
It's now facing directly at you.
Careful not safe front when it's firing, though.
You have a nice encounter with a bullet bill.
Okay, so...
I didn't do it here, anyway.
There you go.
It's that easy.
Uh...
Wait.
What happens if I...
Oh, nice.
I got a nugget.
All right.
Uh...
Wait, but what happens if I do this?
Oops, that's not it.
What happens if I do that?
Oh, nothing happens.
Okay.
I thought I would open another area.
I realized I already got to the end of the area.
Down I go.
Town of the clouds.
Oh, I'm back.
I'm in the city now.
Welcome to cloud...
Cloud cap.
The mushroom of town above the clouds.
Things have been peaceful lately.
Thanks to Princess Daisy's commandeering Bowser's airship.
It's inconceivable that town council won't add hand wheels.
Is it that the bullet bill encountered?
But I got a bullet bill already.
If I hit myself with a bullet.
Hey, Mario!
Do I do it for you?
You're surely not going to pass it up.
It's a one extremely rare, extremely powerful button-a-boo.
I have a fresh ultra-rare button-a-boo that I'm graciously willing to sell you for generous 500 coins.
Well, $500.
That's my Mario.
I'll be taking that.
And use your bonafide, ultra-rare, and useful button-a-boo.
Change it.
Or don't.
I can't really care unless that...
What a deal!
What's a pot-a-boo?
Wait, what is that?
No way!
A toad would not scare me.
He's not smart enough for that.
Look!
Oh, he's so cute!
Wait, he's fire!
Prevents freezing.
Wait, he's actually better than a fucking Magikarp.
What do you mean scam?
Look at him!
I already have a fire-type, so...
Wait.
Let me see.
How do I...
Okay, I need to put in my party to nickname him.
Alright, give me a sec.
You're just gonna be there for one second, Husky.
Don't worry.
I'll replace you later.
I ain't having no bug Pokemon in my party.
Alright, nickname.
Alright!
Who was it that wanted to be a Bullet Bill?
Well, here's your lucky day.
You get to be something even better.
Um, this guy.
This guy.
I'll call you...
Pee-goon.
Hehehehe.
Alright.
He's almost like a bullet.
He's practically a bullet.
It's just that instead of made of steel, he's just lava.
Oh, wait.
I need to...
There's my Pee-goon.
Alright.
Let's be put you in here.
Maybe I should, like, have a...
You know what?
Every foo I see, I'll catch.
So we can make sure everybody has a fun time.
Oh, no.
I thought I'd be able to find some sweet deals on the square today.
But seems like that over there is talking politics again.
Oh my god, what?
What kind of politics are you talking here?
Now I'm scared to ask, but can I be a thump?
Not so dead, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Looks like I'm not going to be able to get any thump here today either.
Better head on over to the store instead.
Don't worry, not so dead, poor.
I got you something better.
Mark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I feel like the PC is getting a little busy.
Oh, not the bitty buds, though.
Oh,
you're lucky.
It's the invasion of the bitty...
They're guarding the...
They're guarding the other bonds.
They're like, take me instead.
Don't worry.
I'm patient.
Alright.
Let me send out Dragoon here.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, Piku.
Hey, Dougie, do you know that Piku sounds like butt and bannery?
Jay, thank you for the super chat.
There you think you'll go lick him.
Another one.
Love my Dragoon.
My little guy.
Alright.
He's a little freaky one there.
Not so good.
Crit.
Crit him.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Look, John.
You got some help.
Oh, and it's also female.
Why am I catching all the female ones?
Alright.
Alright, where do I need to go?
Oh, I need to go here.
Oh.
You need something?
I'm getting ready for the trek to the airship.
Oh, no.
Yeah, yeah, Grandpa.
There's a million times you told the council story.
There's been literally anything else.
Please.
Back in my day, we used to have an entire council of toads.
Why won't anyone believe me?
Grandpa, I don't think that's a good thing, Grandpa.
Maybe, like, you know, we gotta have, like, other types...
Other types of citizens in the council.
Sure!
Don't tell my wife that I got some special berries!
That were a battle against Daisy!
Oh, nice.
Oh, wait!
This toad married outside of toads!
Oh, my God!
My wife...
Wait, what?
My wife loves to hear...
Wait, this is not the wife?
Who's this guy?
I thought this toad married him!
My wife loves to hear...
I gotta get that pirate star from Daisy to ensure happiness.
I better find ways to prepare a deal with ground type...
Wait!
Are they both...
Oh!
They're both...
Oh, I thought this was a man!
Toad!
Oh!
I was like, wait a minute.
Lesbians!
I see!
Yuri!
This is a great spot for my future home.
And with that loan I got on Main Street...
I have the capital to make it a reality.
Now then, do you think the realtors around me accept purple coins?
Koomba, I don't know if you're allowed to live here.
Also, I don't think it's safe for you.
Strange!
How'd I even end up here?
Oh, well.
Better make the most of it.
Hey, you.
Over here.
Who?
Oh, is that Captain Toad?
Hey, wait a minute.
You're Mario.
Oh, thank goodness.
I'm saved.
I'm Captain Toad.
Don't ask out.
But I'm stuck here.
Do you think you can find a way to save me?
I'll make it worth your while.
Oh, wait.
Maybe there's a lock to do somewhere around here.
If not, I hear Princess Daisy's in the air with a whole airship.
Though I don't know how you convinced her to use it to help me.
Oh, I want Daisy to help you.
You seem like a nice guy.
You have your own game.
You're Mario, aren't you?
I'm Mario Bowser was recently sitting around here.
I just can't help but worry for my family's safety.
Am I taking a CM?
All right, nice.
What did I get?
Let him ride.
I never played Captain Toad.
My sister...
Sister?
There's no way Daisy will let Bowser anywhere near us.
Oh my god.
It's like citizens come here to escape Princess...
Like, to escape the tyranny of Toad Town and Princess Peach.
And, like, be whoever they want to be with.
With no prejudice...
What so ever.
Look at how inclusive and diversified this place is.
You know what?
I think Daisy is a better princess than Princess Peach.
Sigh!
Princess Daisy is so dreamy.
She even managed to steal that airship from Bowser, soaring through the skies.
Showing all the world her beauty.
Hey, Mario!
I'd be careful going ahead to Toad Town.
Bowser has recently been spotted in the area.
I don't think he's been all happy since his airship got stolen.
I don't understand what these girls see in Princess Daisy.
I mean, they're much more beautiful things in this world.
We love Tomboys.
Kuma, thank you.
Super chap, thank you.
Thank you.
We can't even see Rainbow run from here for Star's sake.
Oh, he doesn't like the pop progressive, Daisy.
Daisy's rule is...
Oh my god, no wonder the grandpa was like, Back in my day, the council was only Toad's.
Oh my god, the grandpa's racist.
I just realized.
Hey you!
Come by, Star.
You won't regret it.
Oh no.
It all makes sense now.
I can't believe the grandpa's racist.
Okay, we need...
We'll get...
Three more.
I called it.
I feel like usually these guys don't...
Usually don't say much.
Grandpa.
Grandpa, no!
Let's go.
Oh, what?
Oh, this is Cloud City?
Alright, let's see.
Oh dear.
It seems the Koopa Troopa is taking over his route!
There's not much a loaded guy like me can do against him!
Wait, why are you fighting me?
Oh no, it was some random while.
I was like...
I can't guard, so I'll fight you instead.
I was like so confused.
You can do one space jump for the raw nut or you can attempt the one space diagonal jump for the super nut.
You know what?
I got this.
Guys, did I do it?
Oh yeah, you got me!
Bro, you need to stop telling people to make that jump.
It's literally impossible.
Here in Cloud Kingdom, no one chooses to jump for the super nut.
It's better to be safe until the one space jump for the nut rather than risk 1,500 coins for just 20...
What?!
He took back...
I got scammed!
I'm
fucking scammed all of them!
They ran up!
It's like, what's that thing called?
They literally like, fucking set the shit up!
You are not a parkour guy.
Guys, I didn't get...
I didn't save, guys.
No one jumped.
It was a set up!
They sent me up!
I wish the council was still around.
We let those shy guys into this town and look what happened.
We shouldn't have let those shy guys in here.
Mario, you're fast but not fast enough.
Goons!
Please don't call us that, Lord Bowser.
Okay, look, there's a goon.
Oh, sorry.
Minions!
They already got goons.
You hear that, Johnson?
We're minions!
Woo!
I gotta tell my wife about the promotion, Timmy!
Woo-hoo!
Will you two quiet down?
Your king is about to command you.
Super charge the launchers!
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, wait.
Am I just gonna get bullet-billed?
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
Now they lock on and are automatic.
Goodbye, Mario!
Hey, bro!
I'm over here!
What?
Oh, no!
Ah!
Wait right there!
I'm coming over, Mario!
There we go!
Oh!
Oh, my God!
Look at those!
Close one, am I right?
That was a little too much excitement for me.
So, I'm gonna head back to town.
Yeah, go ahead and beat down Bowser for me.
Got it?
Good luck, bro!
Bro, he's got the moons!
Why can't you do that regularly?
Is it just...
Oh, wait, but they're red.
Wait, are they different?
Oh, wait, they're shiny!
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, we'll see.
We'll see if you can.
There's, like, so many of them, though.
They're not that special if they're shiny.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
It's, like, a red Gyarados.
But, like, there's 20 of them.
Sorry, P-goon.
This could've been you.
It's...
Red is faster.
You're right.
Let's see.
Do we give...
Let's have to counsel the side of your face.
Do we give Gus his bullet bill?
Do we give Gus his Gus-goon?
Yay or nay?
Yes.
I didn't know I could...
There could be red Pew Pews.
Can you kill my last incarnation?
Solid, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yay or nay?
Gus-goon.
Alright, I see...
Gus, you're...
The counsel has decided.
There's more yes than nays.
You are lucky they like you.
Or you would have...
The food face.
Hehehehehe.
Hehehehe.
You could've been food.
I bet you never faced these before.
Oh, he looks cool.
Wait, that looks so cool.
The trooper grunt.
Alright.
Goodbye.
I've used fire.
Goodbye, bullet pee.
Yay.
Oh, 69.
Nice.
Yeah, right.
The goon.
Wait, is it just all bullets?
He's just trying to shoot me.
Yippee!
Bro, it's a mare.
Oh my god.
Oh, I wonder what else is he gonna send.
Oh, wow.
Another bullet bill?
Okay, but...
Oh, it's like...
It's basically like Team Rocket.
With like the...
It's basically Team Rocket with the Rattatas and the Zubats.
This guy just has like three Zubats.
How?
Whoa, I wonder how.
Bro, is this trying to shoot me?
Alright, I swear.
If it's just bullet bill, I swear to god.
Mio, you're not gonna get hold of this bill blaster.
Okay, no.
Oh, it's a hornet.
Oh, it's a rat trooper.
The ant trooper's evolution.
Boom.
Goodbye.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god.
We're so close.
35 levels left.
Oh yeah.
He evolves and wears...
He evolves and wears a fucking hat.
That's just evolution.
He just finds a hat.
He's like, don't worry.
I'm different now.
I have a hat.
Alright, nice.
Goodbye.
Give me your money.
Is there anything here?
Alright, guys.
I think I'm gonna stop it here so I can rest my voice.
I've been...
There's been too many toads.
There's...
I think it's a good stopping point.
But I've been enjoying it so far.
I hope you guys have been enjoying watching, too.
Playing like a...
Sort of like a Pokemon game again.
Yeah, too much toad voice acting.
I need a rest.
I've been reading a lot this week, too.
Like, I had to read for yesterday's stream.
And then there was like some reading for other streams.
So I'm gonna rest my voice.
I'm gonna rest my voice today.
But it's been really fun.
Um, I've been enjoying the Super Mario mod.
And like seeing all the different designs.
And all the different mechanics and stuff.
And, um, you know, having you guys be part of the journey.
Being part of my team.
And everything.
Um.
But yeah, guys.
I hope you all enjoyed watching me today.
Wait.
Before I go.
What did you say?
What did Mehdi say?
I've been enjoying...
I think the long count paid off.
Put me in the next one.
Okay.
Mehdi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where am I going back to?
Alright.
Before I end it.
Oh, look.
That's such a cute spiny.
Oh, you.
Oh, wow.
Wait.
Where is she going?
Hey, we're lucky.
It might be a shiny, too.
Oh, nope.
Not you.
There's a long card, right?
Maybe.
Oh, man.
It'll be unfortunate.
Oh, there you go.
Perfect.
Oh, you thought I was going to run away.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let me...
You fool.
Oh, hey.
It's a male this time.
You get to be the only male fool.
Oh, boy.
Variety.
All right, nice.
You were so close.
That wasn't what I wish...
Genie, this is the monkey paw.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
Jagoon will die for the cause.
The monkey paw, girl.
All right, Maddie Goon.
All right, nice.
Eventually, I'll find a shiny fool, right?
Wait, okay.
The moment we get to a...
A daycare center, I'm going to put two.
I'm going to...
Is the fool like a ditto?
I'll just make an entire box of food.
All right.
There you go.
I'll start...
I'll start hatching, though.
I...
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The irony is I want it to be a fool.
All right.
Okay, let's...
Oh, we have just enough.
All right.
Put him here.
And then we'll put...
You here.
Okay.
And...
Oh, we don't...
We need one more.
And then...
And then we'll...
Put beanie...
I think it's better if it's like here.
All right.
Wait, here we go.
This is better.
We just need one more.
And then we complete it.
And then my...
The collection will be complete.
Uh...
There we go.
Wait.
Actually, it should be in the...
Yeah, there we go.
And then we'll have one more.
We'll catch one more here.
Well...
I mean, we can also do like this, too.
But we need like...
I want that...
We need like two more back here, though.
Um...
Actually, this is better.
Actually, this is actually better.
This is...
I like that.
All right.
Nice.
Congratulations, Gus.
Yeah, you're a shot.
Oh, wait.
It's red, too.
Wait.
I forgot this is the red one.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
It's perfect.
No.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Nice.
I think that's a good way to end it here.
All right.
Through today's stream.
What is happening?
Hey, guys.
Have fun watching.
We have a lot of series.
We got it complete.
I just realized.
But...
I hope you guys have a lot of fun watching.
I will keep going with...
I will keep going with part two of this.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks, boss.
My dream come true.
Man.
We need a lot of foos, guys.
Chicory, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, Chicorita here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As always, everybody.
Everybody, stay hydrated, pause your check, give them a round to get that blood flowed.
And if you step from me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!